phew hello my friends
and haters there I know there's some
watching but mostly friends I like the
family members we like to address them
thank you guys for being here on this
wonderful Wednesday we're off the rails
as usual as uh is required of us on
Wednesdays today's episode
doesn't work either today's episode is
sponsored by PayPal honey
three grandmother yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
just I just want to be left alone
thank you
thank you guys uh I'm just loving the it
doesn't work for me either that's for me
either it doesn't work for me either oh
see it doesn't work either
I can't get over Crowders just trying to
live his life right now like he's
posting all this crap to Twitter like
he's doing his normal like racist
homophobic stick
and it's like dude
um
you took a fat L brother you can't just
ignore it like look at his Twitter
uh he has Alex Jones on today hmm
he's a regular now
since the move to rumble oh is Alex on
Rumble I think so
Alex is looking very Joe Rogan uh
physique today
you mean good very top heavy you mean
hot you're very top heavy
[Applause]
um
here is just lots of Alex Jones we love
him abortion is human sacrifice well
that's a good take
um
let's hear what they have to say that's
interesting well think about abortion
abortion I don't know who described it
this way it is sacrifice at the altar of
I love the I love this Lighting on here
it looks like the life has just sucked
out of Stephen
this man you're you're sitting here
talking about abortion you're blowing
cigar smoke in your wife's face when she
was pregnant brother
yeah come on man well think about
abortion abortion I don't know who
described it this way it is sacrifice at
the altar of self it's actual human
sacrifice and even if people want to say
sacrifice
for what at the altar of the self the
altar of the cell okay deep man hey hey
uh Crowder was the last time you saw
your kids
just curious because last I heard they
like were out of state like far away
from him and his wife is raising the
kids without him [__] watch it so if
you want to talk about abortion you
should try being a dad first
okay
because you have the baby then you need
the dad
you know I was thinking too about
Crowder he's such a piece of [__] he was
making fun of people with Down Syndrome
a couple weeks ago how can you be
pro-life pro-life says kids with Down
Syndrome were having them they all
deserve to live so he goes you need to
have the baby with Down Syndrome I'm
forcing you but when the baby with Down
Syndrome is born then we're gonna also
make fun of him do you are you you heard
the Devil bro
like
do you know what I'm saying it's crazy
didn't even really think about that
until the other night when I wasn't on
the air
it's like some pro-life dude
embryo okay but at the point where you
look at the abort abortion policies in
California and Colorado in Virginia no
one denies that you're ending a life and
the only what oh yeah lots of people
deny that dummy stupid ass dumbass yes
many people debate that
actually I would say there's probably a
consensus somewhere
[Music]
maybe I put it another way you're a
bunch of [__] you hit the button yeah
got a little carried away
I felt that uh
button I didn't want to go there okay
fair enough
yeah I get it
I regret it I'm listening to my
intuition that's gonna be the earliest
button so far I'm listening to my
intuition when I say something I
remember correct and I feel that like oh
oh yeah just hit it I appreciate it love
it that's cool because you don't have
forever to you the windows
it's not always open
the reason at that point when you look
at a very small percentage are incest or
rape the vast majority are because
someone doesn't want to raise the baby
well notice that well you don't want to
raise your kids what's your argument
where are your kids gag drill or I mean
Crowder wait what's his name Stephen
where are your [__] kids dude who
doesn't want to be a father
You Know Where Your Children Are he does
not even incredible
flesh they said hell yeah I killed that
kid yeah they have T-shirts yeah you're
bragging about it yeah I know it's about
such losers bro come on get your life in
order stop this silliness
so that's what Crowder's up to but
that's not what I'm here to talk about
today real quick is Crowder's sitting in
the leprechaun chair why was that
Alex outfit him out of his own chair
I did notice that too well it is respect
for the king of being a psychopath the
slot bucket King baby greatest ever do
it he's the best that ever sold slot
bucket tell you what boy nobody sold
slot buckets like the Alex Jones but
guys we have a great episode today
actually you know
different than what we usually do here
uh today's episode if you guys didn't
hear us sponsored by PayPal honey we
have a Teddy fresh drop coming out
tomorrow just to quickly show you guys
this my fawn way this uh wonderful
tie-dye artist
um it's gonna be I want to wear them but
they're all green and I'm in front of a
green screen
and I don't have the black and white one
and I wore this one on Monday
you know what I'm saying yeah Friday
Friday Friday baby that's my one day to
wear green
uh so that's coming out and then also
the Live show tickets are going on sale
tomorrow at right tomorrow at 12. four
members here's how it's gonna work
there's a special code
that will make it viable so on Discord
and in a members only Community post we
will share that code at 12. right you
guys will have 24 hours exclusive access
to buy the tickets and then whatever's
if the tickets will then on Friday at 12
24 hours later go on sale for everybody
correct nailed it
there was a lot of confusion before the
show so and so uh that that's really
exciting the show's on June 23rd we're
all very excited the theater is gorgeous
yeah it's going to be at the theater at
the Ace Hotel is what it's called Uh
such of
stunning theater it is one of the
classic uh movie palaces here in Los
Angeles uh in downtown Los Angeles uh
originally built by United Artists and
Charlie Chaplin way back in the day
um you pulling up a photo yeah
oh
oh there it is there's a better photos
in there
and also built by the ace family they
have their own Ace family oh wow
is that thing structurally sound Austin
McBroom built that place so here it is
it's stunning you guys it's really
really cool look at that building
we're gonna be on that stage Golly Golly
it's a lot more tickets it's 600 tickets
there I am quite I'm a little bit
nervous that
I don't know sometimes I worry that
people don't buy them
brother that's gonna sell out in a
minute I don't know
have a little faith it's a lot more than
last time
have a little faith I think you can get
Butts in those I have I have fear of
Performing to like five person audience
there'll be more on the stage than in
the audience
hey everybody did you like that joke sir
all right it'll be fun in its own way it
would be it would be interesting it's
like open mic night
somebody ask uh can we have the ticket
prices so the tickets are going to range
uh I believe the at the low end at 35
for uh for the cheap seats um and up to
I think it's like
you know what let me let me just look it
up because I don't want to misspeak and
then get people mad at me guys I tried
my best to make them as affordable as
possible but this shit's expensive we're
putting on the theater's expensive the
production because we're live streaming
it that adds a whole dimension and also
we're gonna go all out on the production
of putting on a fantastic show so you
know we're gonna have uh
all the good stuff there
sorry just one more second I'm pulling
up the spreadsheet with all the tickets
do you think it would be a good or bad
idea to throw pizzas like a frisbee out
to the audience as an act of generosity
to our fans who came I mean I suppose we
could oh one very important note that I
just remembered that is different than
last time uh this show will be uh 18
plus okay
um last time
Ethan wanted to show everybody the
prolapse oh we really shouldn't because
this we didn't advertise this is 18 plus
and we don't know could be underage
people in the audience probably not with
our audience to be honest but just to be
on the safe side but this time
it is an 18 and up show so expect some
uh wild ass [__] to be shown to you okay
wait can we show the prolapse I need to
get clearance from our lawyer but my my
whole dream for that was to get the
audience reaction to right the prolapse
video because you all deserve
uh to see that you know it's not fair
that only
guess on this show get to see it you
guys are just as important
okay I have the prices so the base
prices are again 35 for the cheap seats
and then it they're 55 tickets which is
the vast majority of them uh and then
there's uh 70 tickets and then there's
front row tickets premium stuff uh for
150 big ones no but that's very limited
that's that's literally just the front
row the the vast majority is 55. to me
that seemed a little expensive but
honestly it was so it was hard to lower
it more and then the processing feed I
don't know I hate doing this [__] I I
want to make it as cheap as possible
Ethan was pushing to lower the price but
really you I remember you did uh one of
your Tuesday member only streams yes and
you kind of pose the prices to everybody
and the feedback was now that seems
pretty reasonable and we did some
research comparing it to other similar
sizes
it actually this actually was cheaper
than what a lot of others and I know
they're not doing better shows than us
hell no no the last show was a band
is like what the last puck or what are
those uh political guys uh the Obama
guys oh theirs was crazy
um
yeah what are the um
pod save America pod save America twenty
dollars to see just see a couple of
middle-aged dudes Talk Shop like they
don't do nothing
it's pretty crazy they don't do nothing
about nobody but yeah that was all of
our attitude here on the crew too um but
we all actually go and see shows and
Ethan
when was the last time you paid to go to
a concert me yeah what do you think I
don't know 20 years so yeah here's what
here's uh alternatively Chad's saying
totally reasonable super cheap super
cheap okay good now we should say that's
before processing fees and unfortunately
we had to use AXS this time last time we
used we're forced to use it by the video
yeah the venue has a deal with them so
we have to use them and y'all know how
that goes so they'll they'll be some
processing fees
unfortunately uh yes these people asking
about dice dice was what we used last
time they were great but we are not
permitted to we wanted to use we wanted
to use them because it was such a racket
these you know these venues the nice
venues they have exclusive deals with
these big ticket Monopoly companies and
they kick them back to work exclusively
with them it's just it's so [__]
crooked dude because dice is a better
service just also despite being way less
yeah and I was very impressed because I
mean when we put them on sale the the
rush of traffic was insane and I was a
little worried because you know it's not
Ticketmaster AXS that we were going to
crash the website or something but it
handled all the traffic just fine so uh
you know but um not this time
it's uh what time's the show at like
eight or something bro uh I will tell
you right now by the way show this is
this is POD save America here's what
costs 150 bucks to watch these idiots
just sit in chairs please
did you even enter the stage on a
Mobility uh machine right right
and this is going to be you guys during
the live uh this is PNP while watching
this video the pro lab right okay so
doors are at seven show is at eight
there it is
on again Friday June 23rd and a reminder
that this will be our final show before
we take a short summer Hiatus so it's
going to be just kind of like the last
live show uh somewhat of a finale in a
way and we'll probably do another live
show then right before our winter break
yeah I mean we're still feeling it out
but um uh when we first started talking
about doing this again we weren't sure
how frequent they'd be but um I think
we might establish a little tradition
we'll do it live and also somebody says
are the seating assigned yes yeah yeah
sign seating you'll get a signed seating
yep so you don't have to worry about
like showing up early and elbowing
people
so there it is so I'm we're all real
excited about that you know
so uh
looking for tomorrow at 12 o'clock our
time Pacific time I guess just to
clarify and uh we will likely be live on
leftovers pretty wrapping up the show
tomorrow when we do it so we'll do you
know we'll shout it out when that
happens and then like Ethan said it'll
be a 24 period 24 hour period for
members and then on Friday it'll open up
to general admission but
we'll do it live just a warning last
time the members we did the same exact
thing and we opened it up to members
that [__] sold out in like 30 seconds it
was half the tickets if you are it was
half the tickets but if you're
determined
you're determined to see the show I
would recommend grabbing in a membership
this is a serious message to everybody
wanting to see our live show right now
peace and love
thank you Renee for the donors
um okay good that's all very exciting
uh also the BTS is going up uh after
today's episode so all kinds of treats
and treasures
okay but let's move on now so today at
two o'clock Ali London will be calling
into the show to have a kind and civil
gracious uh uh conversation with us
uh many of you know Ali London he was
the uh man who went trans racial he
wanted to become jimin jimin is that
they say that right
jimin I'm not confident enough to cry to
be honest jimin I thought it was jimin
jimin from BTS yes and uh he is an
Englishman who Moved Korea he changed
his race apparently which was obviously
controversial but now
his new
uh plot in life is even more interesting
he has become
a frequent guest on shows like
uh Fox News the late great Tucker
Carlson
uh Newsmax he found Jesus and now he
realizes that being trans
is actually
uh the greatest threat to civilization I
believe he said
as well as trans children in particular
yeah yeah so so that should be
interesting I'd love to kind of hear
about his
his transition from his transition of
course not is you know from one to the
other not not like a gender transition
because he's against that
one time his Odyssey yes so um so
that'll be at two I'm looking forward to
talking to the great Ali London
tasks look fantastic
also so you guys know that the writer
strike is happening there's no like TV
shows and I'm gonna say it right here
proudly we're the only game in town baby
get all your friends who are like I got
nothing to watch bring them here
you know this is our time the late night
shows uh have all ceased production as
of uh yesterday not us all of you
welcome to all Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Fallon
uh Seth Meyers fans all the jimmies hi
girl Olivia says uh yes and support to
all of our writers friends in the wga I
personally have a couple friends in
there I was talking to yesterday and uh
they uh they're completely in the right
and they deserve everything they're
asking for so uh
back down but with all that being said
it's gonna suck when they lose all their
audience to us
free content that's so good I should
have just give them what they wanted
come on come to Daddy
uh the writer's uh strike is of course
yeah it's good I mean unionize uh get
what you uh what you what you're owed I
mean you know [__] all these [__]
these Pro are these you know IP owners
scumbags
let's see they failed to reach an
agreement over Equity apparently the
problem is that traditionally writers
get uh
residual payments on TV shows and since
the age of streaming
now the same writers who are writing for
same big shows are not getting
residuals in the same way like I saw
someone say that where they used to get
like ten thousand dollars in residuals
they're now getting like 300.
so their their cut has been or their pay
has been significantly cut cut them off
I don't know why the writers get shafted
it's like uh
it's not just the writers to be kind of
an important Bearer the industry has
evolved a lot in the last decade as
everybody knows
um and their contract not kept up with
that
um and so this is the opportunity and
there's uh from what I understand a very
good chance that the Director's Guild
will also
um because they their their contract is
also up for negotiation very soon and
they have a lot of the same things going
on with them so uh yeah it's uh
it's going to be interesting to see how
it plays out because this is going to
kind of set the uh
set the precedent for a lot of the
negotiations to come in the next couple
years it says 2007 lasted four months
the Riders strike and resulted in 1.5
billion dollars of loss for the city of
La it's like that cannot have been worth
it for who are they negotiating with uh
the producers uh Association Guild I
forget what they like Ryan Kavanaugh
types folks yeah scumbag knew he was a
scumbag
Ryan can you hear that guys Ryan
Kavanaugh is preventing these good
hard-working people thank you from
getting the money they deserve thank you
just kidding or I mean that's a joke
he's not producing that I can't stop
saying thank you like Ryan Kavanaugh
thank you like just in my everyday life
it's it totally affected my brain that
doesn't work for me either either that's
my new one
either
so let's go
it doesn't work either either
it doesn't work for me either either
anyway
sounds like laser tag yeah an update
also on the um the Hassan copyright
situation with Aiden Ross
Aiden bitched out
and he dropped the uh
he dropped it actually YouTube seemed to
have intervened which is pretty cool
uh okay Jesus I hate that one
God checked on this and it looks like
the claim has been closed by the content
owner okay so they they closed it
they back down he bailed
here's Hassan talking about it
oh you know what I need to make a
correction because my analysis as a not
an attorney
was that
Aiden owned the content but I talked to
my attorney
about it that night and my attorney said
that he thinks that a song would
in the case of a lawsuit of a decent
argument at
co-authorship okay
I mean that logically makes sense right
like the content doesn't exist without
him he's a direct participant but like
what you were saying the other day it
kind of made sense to me too because
it's like it is Aiden's recording so
yeah I don't know what makes sense I
mean theoretically yeah you'd think that
Hassan would be entitled to it right so
but it's I guess it's untested you know
but he thinks he could make a decent
argument about co-authorship but at the
end of the day the issues resolved and
nobody should get into a lawsuit if they
don't have to trust me don't want that
[__] in your life yeah in fact I just
heard that
on the defamation lawsuit of Ryan
cabcavs
we're gonna there's a chance a good
chance that we're gonna have to enter
mediation in June which means that me
and Ryan and our attorneys have to go
you're one of your license
so you're gonna sorry go ahead you're
gonna have a name we have to go
to the same place to meet with a
mediator to see if we can hash it out
now here's the thing we'll be in
separate rooms next to each other and
they'll be going back and forth but we
can go meet face to face if we want in
fact it's probably going to be
encouraged by the mediator
I love that so much
I'll be like a Ryan baby
BTS live stream all of it yeah I don't
think I can do that
like spy cam that'd be that would
probably not be amazing you're gonna
bring a hunk of meat and the thing to
squish it so you can squash the beef
okay
I hadn't thought about that
right now there's just this Great Divide
you know there's a fight
I feel like we can resolve it if I see
him face to face I'll be like right my
man come on do you really want to keep
going dab me up brother
lunch with Bryce right let's go catch
runs with our boy
smoothies with Brad the bowl
thanks for taking care of her yeah I
don't know how
how hot he's gonna be I'm over it I
don't care either way you know I'm just
here for the ride right I have that's
all I've been here for I didn't do this
if he did this
but he should know by now that I'm not
going anywhere I'm not like
I don't give a [__] first-hand
experience I just don't because we have
bigger problems to deal with at this
point I would assume so and I'll tell
you one thing that Kev cab doesn't want
which is what's gonna happen
uh
eventually if he does want to go forward
with this discovery
depositions right right because that boy
I got nothing to hide you can depose me
you can discover me what you want a
couple emails a couple of whatsapps
that's fine
or you want to talk about Discovery my
boy I want to look through all of your
financial records for triller angry
because if you're gonna accuse me of
defamation well let's see you know we
need to understand if what I said or not
what I said but what variety headline
said
um it's true right were you gonna be in
a great position to say hey okay
we need to verify uh are you doing a
Ponzi scheme
so we need access to all the records all
the financial records of uh your failed
bankrupt uh Film House
interesting
we don't know that Ja Rule we don't know
thank you well we don't know we don't
know yeah we don't know
but we'll but but we'll attempt to find
out and I know for sure your boy don't
want none of that probably not because
there seems to be just a little shady
bookkeeping if I had to make an
assumption an educated guess
all kinds of silliness going on in the
books there a capcav
mm-hmm
so we'll see Captain we'll see how I'm
gonna see how you dab me up on that day
1.3 million and I'll see how generous
I'm feeling the one suggested maybe you
should wear a Habitat for Humanity
shirts
oh man that's or
what if you wore Ian's shirt but it's
edited to be you and kafkaf I think I
saw someone do that I think that'd be a
beautiful thing to show up in that would
be fun that would be fire yeah because
like together what is it what is it
again the other we United divided United
We Stand
I think that's beautiful I'm not
standing with him though just to be
clear united we sit yeah I don't want to
sit next to him too much wine alcohol
if you're not in the same room and but
you're in like adjacent rooms should
start like
pounding on the wall I heard about that
I heard I thought about that I was gonna
go Ryan
there will be a mediator there so I I I
don't want to rock the boat but yeah I
thought about that
just plain bull sounds really loud
but that'll be interesting you know [__]
you know
lawsuits are so stupid
you know I'm I'd be happy for it to just
go away
but well of course if he wants to Tango
you know I don't care
I'm here for it right right
my calf calf
[Music]
so it's on you right
you want to dance
or you want to retire
because I'm here for both
you want to bark like a dog
oh you want to just chill like a puppy
I can be your night I can be your devil
or I can be your angel
[Music]
I'll be doing that through the wall
slowly unhinged
[Music]
I mean they can't charge me for being
unhinged I mean I'm crazy he knew that
going in I'm CR your honor I'm crazy
laughs
I'm in your walls Ryan
[Laughter]
so
we'll see it should be interesting you
know very very interesting it'll be a
good story either way on the podcast
yeah can't wait
cannot wait I will see two June is uh
shaping up to be interesting it was in
June this year
um we are already at 30 minutes we
should do our ad
um and then
we're we'll only be about 15 minutes out
from our guest calling in all right so
we have one ad here PayPal honey let's
thank them real fast we love so well we
love love love honey
been such a great supporter of our show
I encourage everybody to support honey
and I love honey today's episode is
sponsored by them it's the easy way to
save When shopping on your iPhone or
computer
honey is
free money period I love me honey if
you're shopping on the internet what I
love me honey I love me lucky Honeys My
Lucky Charms
honey I'm telling you man if you're
browsing if you're shopping without it
just stop you don't even have to think
about it dude no you don't need to think
about it here's how it works
works all across the internet talking
technology
gadgets clothing food everything when
you get to the checkout after you add
things to your cart when you're getting
ready to pay honey which is a
browser plugin
which you install in just one click in
the App Store it's couldn't be easier
drops down a notification says hey
we found some coupons because we scoured
the whole internet
to find the juiciest coupon all you got
to do is Click apply coupon and boom
jeez
the price is going to magically
magically drop I mean this is all
genuine savings that have happened to us
I think these are all from Eli I don't
know if any of you guys sent any of
these a couple are from the crew and
then I think even one or two are uh in
uh from fans that have been sent to me
so they're all authentic savings they
are all real they're all real
dude it's so sick
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites when you click check out
the honey button appears and all you
have to do is Click apply coupon
wait a few seconds it's honey searches
for coupons you can find for that site
and if honey finds a working coupon
the prices drop
we love it
you can see it's from ten dollars up to
like a hundred dollars you know
ten percent twenty percent off
and the best part here is that honey
doesn't just work on desktop it works on
your iPhone now too just activate it on
Safari on your phone
and save on the go
if you use this link joinhoney.com H3
it will take you uh straight to the
store I believe to download it so it's
easy
super easy is that right I think it does
somebody in the chat Hannah just said
honey literally saved me almost 100 on a
celebration of life ceremony let's go
honey all right Hannah
ceremony
uh I don't know oh okay congrats
oh a funeral oh I'm sorry well it's good
to jeez Louise but you save money on a
funeral that's the
unexpected places
you said everywhere
you know I mean listen they're gone
they're not gonna need that hundred
bucks they're not gonna care
but you will so download honey that's it
I mean you know
listen if it was my funeral I want you
to save all the money you could
that's for sure that's for sure
well we love honey uh guys go to
joinhoney.com HD they're such a great
supporter of the show so please consider
downloading and supporting honey thank
you thank you with peace and love
this is a serious message
from honey
okay this is interesting I'm kind of
having a viral moment on Tick Tock you
guys hmm
you're the it boy
having a viral moment all even Noah back
uh Mr
flipped Mr flipped himself is featuring
my sound
so what do I get out of this do I get
money is someone paying me uh you're
gonna have to strike for residuals
where's my residuals is anybody coming
and subbing I don't think so but so
flipped but it's cool
you know it's nice to see something H3
related that's not just like overwhelmed
with hate
but probably just because they don't
know but but here's the Noah back uh
uh paying homage to me
also
I don't know does he know it's me
I mean when you click on it the original
is a clip of you yeah so if you click on
the sound uh shout out to famed Flames
who uploaded this also my last two brain
cells trying to form a sentence they
said that's so funny
I don't know
I remember this happening I don't
remember what about but it just happens
sometimes you know it's what it is
also
because what my what's going through my
mind is like I've I've totally lost it
trying to think
buttons let's just cut my losses let's
just cut the losses and move on to
something else yeah that was probably a
good call whatever it was
you know
so but it's it's quite a phenomenon I
have to say that they love me they
really love me
you've got a few viral sounds on Tick
Tock I have yeah not the first time
there was one other one what was it well
there was a lot from Frenemies but there
was one recently
this one has 14 000 videos is that a lot
I feel like with stuff goes Super viral
it's like hundreds of thousands but
we'll get there
it's a work in progress
here is a shout out to Katie tibb who
also uh trailblazed this meme
when I'm spilling the tea and I get a
weird feeling about who I'm telling it
to also
I don't know also so people are liking
it that is so true also so true queen
I'm trying to think about nothing here's
another one also when I'm ranting to my
friend then realize it's sounding a
little too much like gossip
I don't know when did that stop talking
uh it's all the girlies too by the way
shout out to the girls
but me and my bestie have been
dissecting the same tea for four hours I
don't know I have nothing more to add
I feel that I sent the other one almost
has 2 000 posts
two thousand yeah almost so this one
already has more this one is fourteen
thousand
oh
it's going viral baby you're a star
I'm having a viral moment you guys
you are the also when I'm talking about
something but I've gone through a cart a
week every week for three years
what does that mean
like memory
a cart
a cart a week that's like
weed right I thought it was cigarettes
sounds like I've never heard no I think
it's like a pod I think I think it is
reference to it
so is you smoking tobacco or weed it
could be both like weed I think we I
think she's referencing her memory yeah
like she can't remember also
yeah just in case you guys didn't you
gotta watch it I don't know also okay
shout out to the uh weed smokers out
there
this one showed up on my feet naturally
when I'm looking at my boyfriend while
talking to him but all I can think about
is how hot he is so I don't remember
what I'm gonna say okay girl
also
shout out to your boyfriend
I don't know good for him
love that
it's nice to be it's low it's nice to be
loved I love it also when drunk me
remembers that sober me said we can't
tell people that
I don't know
yeah I'm just so relatable that's what's
so cool so true just I'm so so relatable
you guys
here's the other one
um so this oh my God so this one really
is going viral huh 2 000 that's nothing
compared to my meme themed uh viral
moment that's happening right now
again
weird lack of respect for the sanctity
of life again maybe I'm overacting but I
feel like again this this was pretty
funny there are some good ones here yeah
if the US didn't colonize Hawaii you'd
all be speaking Japanese right now
weird lack
of respect for the sanctity of life
so you know again when people pose and
smile with an animal they literally
murdered that's true Queen
shout out weird lack of respective
sanctity of life that is so true so okay
but this one is really popping off you
guys so thank you oh and this one's all
girly too
oh Lena's on here again
when I'm sitting outside with my Arab
dad and he comments on what all the
neighbors are doing
weird black
of respect for the sanctity of life
love you girl preach it girlie
also
when I'm about to Spill the tea and
remember she's friends with the people
involved
I don't okay all right
thank you
what an honor they love me
they really loved me absolutely
[Applause]
you know it's both a blessing and a
curse to be as relatable as I so true
[Music]
thank you I want to say to all the
girlies of tick tock I want to say thank
you for being so kind and thoughtful and
supporting me through all all the ups
and downs you know
for defending me stalwart Defenders Of
Me Against the hordes of alpha brained
Sigma grinders
yes yes it's just us against the world
girlies yes yes
slay City
thank you slay Queen slay Queen City
so we have London is he or Ollie is he
in the chat I mean it's we have nine
minutes uh they are not here yet who's
they huh you said they are not oh that
well he's he goes by he now
are you doing a pronoun thing no you can
call
it's proper English to say they're not
here yet oh Well he but he I'm just
saying I could say it by he okay that's
fine what well I didn't know if you're
talking about I was wondering if you
were meant no I came in somebody else
the Royal they it's the Royal day
bye
um
I heard from Ollie a few minutes ago he
said thank you okay okay cool so we're
just waiting for Ali London to join and
in the meantime London
in the meantime we'll continue through
our Goofs and gaffs you know here this
was a post on the subreddit that I
really enjoyed
forbidden topics this is so good and
actually there was some really good
suggestions
uh to even amend it
ABS Michael Jackson which we found out
on Monday
I'm sorry about that AV we found out
Monday
we had a reminder right yeah mine's
actually two because that picture too so
it's actually one deal
and uh of course Ian's is Kanye West who
if you ask Ian he doesn't even know who
that is anymore right smart who's Kanye
West Dan
don't know we don't know we have no idea
never heard about it
Zach this is Clayton's kleinwater
Revival Revival
clydens kleinwater uh he's up
we don't like to talk about them
actually of all the topics that are off
limits I might say that this is the most
off limits one although the Michael
Jackson and Kanye ones are pretty pretty
high up there
now somebody put nicocado for me which
is funny and true but also Trisha would
be
I was gonna say did yeah I mean you
don't yeah Nick is not the uh but just
because I always put the foot in my
mouth when I talk about Nick right we
but that's the thing it's like for
everybody else it's the topics that they
don't want to talk about
for you it's the one that all of us
don't want you to talk about right
well someone also you don't talk about
anything
true
Ela suggested adding
Ela and then putting Trisha for her
because that's also very that one makes
sense yeah yeah Dan is um
Jimmy Lee Jimmy Lee you could also drag
an arrow from me to Jimmy as well I
think that you off topic that'd be
that'd be appropriate
uh Olivia oh Olivia has uh what's her
face a loser Baldwin idiot Haley Haley
laylee
Sam Sonic is fantastic I love that yep
I thought it was so good though I love
that we all have our sensitive uh issues
huh Hassan being 911 was also really
good yeah that was suggested as well
that would be a great last one just the
Twin Towers on fire
you know it's always a good addition to
any list
so thank you to that that was really
gave me a kick
this was that was a real hoot it was a
hoot yeah we don't use that word enough
it was a hoot I'll give it that I say it
all the time oh that was a hoot oh
wait can you um find a video of this
baby
as you say image
yep
um people were having a laugh I did the
member stream
on Tuesday
and I had a moment where I couldn't
remember my age
oh is this it nice and I um I'll just
show this if he's in then I'll move on
and I I swear I couldn't remember if I
was goddamn 36 or 37 and I am sad too
I've learned that I am in fact 37 after
Googling
someone needs to contact Mr Google let
them know that that's not yeah that's
not Google actually has a function to
say this information is inaccurate it'd
be great if everybody could go correct
that and yeah I could change that easily
oh could you change that yeah to your
proper age 42 as well how is that my
proper age I was born in 42 now I was
born in 85. can you do math
your guys's age gaslighting has
genuinely confused me though because I I
was absolutely confused in this moment
oh I'm 30 I'm not 37.
what did I say that I type Ethan Klein
age and everybody I am 37. oh my God
foreign
[Music]
how old is this guy again like 35 40. No
37 but I'm almost 38 that's crazy that's
[__] crazy but Bobby Lee's 51 it said
here so I was like ah it could be worse
his old ass put that away B I don't see
that
put that away
[Music]
okay how does 42 make sense I was born
in 85 do the math you're just I just did
you were telling me I was born in the
70s
no I'm telling you 42. or that's what
I'm telling you 1981. it doesn't make
any sense though you guys understand it
does if you are lying and in denial
about your birth year let's just move on
that makes sense
let's fight about it's getting pathetic
does that make sense for sense it does
not make sisters sense did you did you
say you see Ollie in there I didn't say
I didn't say that no oh and he's not oh
they're not
okay
uh technically three minutes out
uh we said two o'clock
so we're gonna let three minutes
um this is also interesting we talked
about the MLK of incels as we talked
about on Monday who who got laid and
caused a shitstorm in the community
right somebody messaged him they said
you're getting rinsed on H3 cope harder
so I'm assuming that's a fan right he
told him to co-parter I don't really
everyone seems confused both of these
messages are inaccurate because we
weren't rinsing him we were actually we
were rinsing all of the people that were
arguing yeah we're original right yeah I
was kind of on his side yep you were
calling the MLK yeah I mean you're MLK
bro that's a big that's a big deal uh
he's a revolutionary MLK has a holiday
man right and then their response is
also wildly inaccurate so it's just two
people not knowing what they're talking
about yelling at each other on the
internet yeah so MLK of intels responded
he said by the way whose wife started
and only fans Keck Keck of course which
is super embarrassing to actually write
out in 2023. you can see why it took him
so long to get laid Yeah that's pretty
bad heck is like a World of Warcraft
reference where yeah you were a human
and an orc type the lull it would show
up as Keck that is correct
it's still using no Dan I was there on
Twitch it's pretty common but yeah
anywhere else kind of embarrassing
I think we need to phase out Keck yeah
uh more pathetic than we could ever be
he said well
um
she doesn't have an only fan so I don't
know why you're saying that
but uh
he's he's not getting the facts straight
he's saying more pathetic than we could
ever be yet we were looking at tweets of
him from Monday saying nobody wants to
be an incel right so would you take it
only fans model who's rich as [__] by
the way take care of your broke dumb ass
and get laid or you want to be single
and talk about stinky holes
he's being demoted
he's no longer the MLK
he's more like the uh
uh Rodney Dangerfield
there were a lot of directions you could
go with that and Rodney Dangerfield was
not one that I was anticipating he gets
no respect he gets nervous because he
gets no respect I thought you're just
gonna say like a lesser like civil
rights I didn't want it yeah I thought
about that but then I was like I don't
want to insult sure do not like Rodney
Dangerfield is that is that the point
you're trying to well no I like Rodney
uh but uh
he's more like the Jim Brewer right now
the gym Brewer yeah race relations
all right well all these in the chat
people say he thinks that I'm idubbbz
which is I guess
not that similar or confusing okay I'm
just saying it's not like that similar
you're an Associated I mean I could at
least see where
that might get crossed over because you
guys do collaborate and are friends or
whatever
makes more sense at least okay well
shout out to uh to our boy here
uh yes okay um Ollie is on the chat
we're graced by the presence of Ali Ali
Ali Oxford
and um let's go ahead and bring them on
okay
moment please
we should mute chat for this segment
probably want to as we do during
interviews all right Ethan how's it
going hello Ollie nice to uh and chat
with you
nice to see I like your outfit very
French with the hat oh thank you so much
and you I think you look wonderful too
we're kind of doing the same thing with
our hats aren't we
it wasn't planned but yeah yeah let me
see your profile turn to the side let me
see how it's looking
oh you know I've actually quit surgery
no no I mean the beanie I'm I'm not
commenting on your surgery I'm sorry
sitting you know
yeah no it's very cool uh how's your day
so far so uh we're just getting set up
here a little bit so tell me um
since you when was your last surgery I'm
curious
so I actually quit surgery
um well my last surgery was last April
um but I've completely quit and I'm
never going to do surgery again I had
um like recently I had a non-surgical
facelift but it's no surgery it's Fred's
because you know you can do the same
thing these days without the actual
surgery and I was getting to a point
even where I would have probably died
because I was going to probably gone
under anesthetic three times every year
I was going under anesthetic so it was
like I could have died
um
um you know I I read somewhere that you
spent three hundred thousand dollars on
plastic surgery I've always wondered
like where do you get that's a lot of
money where'd you get that money
well actually I used to before I started
doing you know social media and K-pop
and stuff I actually it was a successful
personal shopper so I had my own
personal shopping business in London so
you know I used to dress like really you
know like very wealthy ladies
celebrities okay like a stylist members
of royal family so you know you dressed
I was dressing them in like Gucci and
Tom Ford and stuff and you get a very
high commission for that
um so basically I did all that spent a
lot of the money on the surgery
um and and now I've got a I've got like
a PR Company basically helping
influencers
um get publicity and help them get
placements in like television and
advertisements and stuff like that and
getting their brand deals um and of
course I do my own social media and I've
got a book as well
um coming out this year right we'll talk
about that but did you say you dressed
members of the Royal Family
uh not the British royal family so I'd
actually
um met with uh Queen Beatrix of the
Netherlands and she shot with me she
bought some uh you did you come back
damn you know I met loads of people I
met you know the prime minister of
Thailand the ex prime minister I used to
shop with his wives and girlfriends wow
uh must have been hard to leave right
behind because you know you moved to
South Korea and we're off here with that
whole journey that must have been hard
to leave all that behind you if you were
doing so well
um actually that was before so there
when I lived in careers in English so
that was actually before so
um it was basically I was younger I
wanted an experience abroad went to do
some teaching in Korea and then after I
got back to London I started like
getting into fashion I had some friends
doing fashion and then you know over a
couple of years I worked my way up from
a stylist to a personal shopper and um
kind of did that for about um four or
five years so let's talk Ali about well
first of all thank you for coming on I
understand you're promoting a book
entitled gender Madness which comes out
August 1st so congratulations this is
your first book uh very exciting gender
Madness also uh you wanted to announce
that you're the new spokesperson for
fairness first Pac Caitlyn Jenner's
organization
who famously ran someone over but that's
actually not the most important thing
about Caitlyn Jenner
um yes so basically I've got a new book
coming out um August 1st and basically a
lot of people have you know obviously
followed my journey over the years and
um obviously I've struggled a lot with
identity and I had some very unhealthy
behaviors basically due to my addiction
to surgery my body dysmorphia which
later turned into gender dysphoria so I
really struggle with that and it was
unhealthy and you know I completely
accept my past you know I don't try to
deny the person I was and you know I had
some kind of bizarre behaviors basically
in an attempt to feel validated and to
try and you know
feel loved because I really resented I
want to get into all those things
um okay I'm I'm really interested in
your journey from
you identified as a trans woman right
and then and then you kind of found God
and pivoted
to becoming a
a white
British Christian man is that do I have
the synopsis correct yeah it sounds
complicated but yes so I'm back to being
myself now and like finally found
happiness okay okay so I just want to
get a few things straight so are you do
you still identify as gay
um yes so I'm still going but I have
dated Girls before and you know still
you're bisexual I guess exactly yeah
okay okay and uh you don't identify as a
Korean anymore
no correct actually and then and then
also are you pro-gay rights
yeah absolutely you know I'm part of the
LGBT community I support people
um my issue is just what's happening to
children and also the erosion of women's
rights but you know I fully support um
people as an adult making an informed
decision to change themselves but I
don't support children being medically
transitioned so you do support trans
people and gender uh in general
so absolutely so I support you know
people as an adult making a decision if
they want to change and they're happy
with that but I feel that unfortunately
the trans movement has been hijacked by
a small but growing group of trans
activists which are basically pushing
kind of an erosion of women's rights so
that's what I really take an issue with
there's a lot of trans people have a lot
of trans friends I know what it's like
to be trans that really just want to
live their lives and they're actually
having a tough time now because of these
trans activists so my issue is with
trans activists and not actual trans
people okay so you say here's a tweet of
yours from just the end of last month
not that long ago
right or no yeah it's like from five
days ago you say the goal of the trans
movement
is not simply to exist the goal is to
erase women
mutilate children sexualize kids take
away free speech class pedophilia as an
identity
uh remove parental rights and Doctrine
indoctrinate kids violence to obtain and
they're willing to do violence to obtain
their goals
so um when you say the trans movement it
seems to me that you are speaking
generally about trans people uh having
this goal and when you say trans
movement I don't know exactly what you
mean because it seems that most trans
people or that I've seen maybe with the
exception of Caitlyn Jenner uh
it seems to uh
disagree with this seems to identify as
being parts of the trans movement so
what is the difference between what is
the trans movement who is a who is a
member of that what is this organization
okay so what I'm talking about here is
the trans movement in this in the trans
activist movement so the people pushing
these ideologies so we see every single
day just yesterday the Texas state
capital was uh invaded their trans
protesters went there we see women being
attacked at women's rights rallies
physically attacked and we're seeing
this trans activist movement pushing um
for gender affirming Care on kids which
is basically putting 11 12 year old kids
on very harmful hormones so that's what
I'm talking about when I talk I'm not
generalizing every single trans person
I'm talking about the current trans
movement which has been hijacked by
trans activists and you know I really
think that trans people that have been
living as a trans person their whole
life they need to speak out against us
because the problem is that the LGBT
community is being hijacked by these
radical things sorry I don't want to cut
you off but I just want to address
things you said already right so you say
that the uh people who are demonstrating
at the Texas capital are part of this
trans movement who wants to you know
sexualize kids and this whole list of
things
um
they were there to protest a bill SB 14
that would ban gender-related treatment
for minors so
um these guys are I guess see that as an
affront as being transphobic
but you disagree because what is minor
anyone 17 and under do you believe that
ever there would be a 17 year old that
needed gender affirming care
um so my notes basically classified
anyone under 18 and what these people
were protesting against was the fact
that Texas is trying to pass a law to
ban
um hormones and puberty blockers and
gender reassignment surgery being
administered to Children basically so
you know I think these people firstly
you know that was an unlawful protest
you can't just go into a state capital
and do that you know are you in favor of
only lawful protests
the law and if they want to have
protests they can have that dialogue but
outside the State House you can't just
storm in a state house I mean it's
comparable to January 6 when people
storm their Capital which was unlawful
as well so I think you know these people
were not protesting about their rights
being taken away it's the fact that they
were protesting against a bill that
would have actually protected children
so I think that's really harmful
some might say that uh it's actually
harming kids right to make it illegal to
do this because as as you probably know
or I think you did at one point is that
a gender affirming Care on people on
children is exceedingly rare it's
actually so rare that it's um
it's it's if to express like
irreversible gender changes on children
is something like you know uh uh I've
got the number here
0.000493 percent of U.S children age
6 through 17 go through irreversible
gender uh
uh changes so I I guess I'm just curious
because in in the cases where they do
undergo it
it's usually uh to save their life right
because they're probably they might be
suicidal or or yeah right and and they
go through like panels they go through
multiple rounds of talking to
psychiatrists and doctors so so I guess
I'm just curious why is it you think
that this is threatening kids instead of
actually helping kids who are at high
risk of uh hurting themselves
so Ethan about 10 years ago when gender
affirming care was performed on whether
that was minors or adults there was a
lot of checks and balances now it has
become so easy so they don't have the
psychiatrist appointments anymore they
don't have you know having to wait
several years to transition now it's a
very fast track process and that's the
real issue because many of these teams
and we're seeing thousands of teams uh
being transitioned and put on hormones
the numbers really gone up in the last
few years now many of these teens are
struggling with other issues there's a
high case um around one in six of these
children have autism they're being
misdiagnosed there's also kids with
depression bipolar and they're being
told it must be all of these issues must
be because they're in the wrong gender
and they are being fast-tracked um there
was a case in Missouri at the Saint
Louis Children's hospital and basically
a whistleblower unveiled that they only
required like one session with a
therapist to get a child on hormones and
puberty blockers so that's the issue
when a system is being exploited and you
know there's been trans people forever
throughout history there's so many
examples of Trans people but the thing
is now is you know previously as
difficult as it was because it's so hard
when you're trans to struggle and to
think every day that I'm trapped in the
wrong body it is horrific to go through
that but the problem is you know years
ago they would have two to three years
they would have to undergo a
psychiatrist appointments doctors
appointments in order to qualify for a
transition now it has become so easy and
there are thousands of kids being fast
tracked and put on hormones
prescriptions and some kids can now go
to States
um like Colorado or Washington state
which have become Sanctuary States I
want to actually address what you said
about um
you had said something about Jamie
Reed's allegations right but that was
debunked right because the parents and
the uh
the children there who actually were
attending that facility actually told a
completely different story have you read
their account of that
yeah so I saw recently that the they did
an internal investigation they said it
wasn't true but you know well that seems
significant
you don't believe the internal
investigation
no because there were multiple parents
when the Daily Caller originally did the
interview of Jamie Reed there were
multiple parents that said basically
their kids weren't looked after once
they left the clinic there were no
checks and balances and there were
parents confirming that so you know I
believe the investigation has a lot of
bias because she's done by the clinic
and they're profiting so the CL so the
internal investigation
said uh there was no uh
there was no wrongdoings the patient
said there was no wrongdoings so I guess
I'm just curious uh the people who are
claiming that there was something wrong
there is like the Daily Caller Tucker
Carlson are you are you saying that they
don't have a bias
well I mean a lot of people have a bias
and stuff but you know we have to look
at these gender clinics as a whole
project Veritas exposed multiple clinics
the other day of talking about medically
transitioning 8 to 11 year olds so we
have to acknowledge that this is going
on in a lot of clinics and a lot of
these clinics are trying to cover their
backs by trying to paint a Rosy picture
that it's perfect by project veritas
yes they did an undercover investigation
uh that's the guy who got ousted for
being like a sex criminal and like scam
artist James O'Keefe that's his
organization right
um he's not part of that organization
now so the organization that he left um
project Veritas the original
organization did this invest they don't
have a lot of credibility Veritas it
seems like every investigation they do
is just chock full holes of uh untruths
and just blatant lies I don't think it's
a very credible Institution for pulling
data from
well there's multiple organizations like
project Veritas that do it which other
ones um so gays against groomers and
ambassador to them they are also
exposing this happening in clinics
gaze against groomers
so who's have you had that I haven't but
who's the groomer then
um so basically goes against groomers is
an organization of hundreds of LGBT
people it includes trans people as well
basically these uh this organization is
calling out the harms uh they're doing
investigations of gender clinics calling
out the harms of doing this to kids
because look we get this thing coming
though that's the part that I find like
really inflammatory because grooming
implies that trans people or trans
activists and it's what you said here in
this tweet that they're pedophiles that
they're sexualizing kids so where does
that evidence come from because it's one
thing to say we're against you know uh
a gender affirming care for minors but
it's a whole different thing to say you
know they're grooming
well that word is basically used because
we're seeing many
um drag shows like adult drag shows
where kids are attending and it's very
sexually explicit so that is a form of
grooming we also see um these kids books
in public libraries and in schools where
they're teaching kids about Dragon being
trans you know that's not a subject a
kids should hear so that is a form of
pruning because it's indoctrinating kids
I've heard I know that there was that
one uh drag show with kids that was kind
of a heartburn issue
um where what other examples uh can you
think of of drag shows with kids uh
involved where they're being groomed
um in the last year there's a an
investigative journalist Taylor Hansen
he's exposed at least 20 drag shows in
Texas that are called drag shows uh
they're called all ages drag shows and
they're basically doing sex acts on
stage they have their breasts you know
they're doing very inappropriate things
so no it's just so hold on sorry you're
making so many claims and I just want to
get to each one uh you mentioned the
organization gaze against groomers
which was founded by Jamie Mitchell is
that right
So Jamie Mitchell and their partner
Ultra Mega Trump followers and there's
nothing wrong with uh being a trump
supporter but they're also
anti-transgender they spread anti-digit
propaganda with Q Anon conspiracy
theories and and interestingly the
founders are straight
so how is it that they can make a gaze
against a Groomer's organization when
they themselves are not even gay that
seems disingenuous
well firstly that's a Wikipedia page you
know Wikipedia has a lot of bias with
the um woke um people that write Jamie
Mitchell is gay
she's gay She's a Lesbian all of the
people you have to be LGBT to be a
member
so there's anything to verify the
credentials
no I mean you know if someone says
they're they're gay or bi you know you
accept that you don't say oh can you
prove that you're gay how can you prove
that so I mean no Jamie Mitchell is a
lesbian all of the members are lesbians
trans it's not anti-transgender at all
they support people being trans as an
adult but what they're trying to do is
calling out the harm that we're seeing
um caused to children and that's the
real issue here is about protecting kids
so go back to your claim about grooming
so you you brought up uh the drag show
for kids
um
is there any other examples or are we
just talking about drag shows because I
have to assume that the drag shows even
if it says widespread as uh project
Veritas claims which Heaven Knows uh how
credible they are there's got to be
other examples to to make such bold
claims is that there's a whole movement
trying to sexualize kids
yeah I mean even if you look at the
music industry you have really shocking
performances like Sam Smith for instance
who is
um pushing a specific agenda he has
concerts which are allowing all ages and
you know if you want to be a musician do
whatever you want but don't be doing
sexually graphic things he's doing uh
imitating [__] he has you know
fetish gear on and there's kids in the
audience so it's not just about drag
queens it's about protecting kids in
general so even if it's even if it's
cardi B you know I don't think kids
should be at a cardi B concert if she's
twerking or doing like something very
very sexual I think it's just about
protection I mean but you know you you
turn on the TV I mean you see stuff
worse than that right on YouTube and
stuff right to see they're grooming them
seems pretty pretty disingenuous and
actually really homophobic and
transphobic too but this label that
they're groomers because you understand
the gravity of such a claim right
well it's a very loaded word I I get
that but it's not an attack on the LGBT
community at all it's about basically
calling out specific cases it's not an
attack on trans people calling out
specific cases where children are being
exposed to something that's highly
inappropriate and trying to raise
awareness of that so it's not a label
that's attached to gay people lesbians
trans people it's literally about
calling out specific instances I want to
ask you about doing something specific
actually since you bring it up I have
seen something troubling from uh a trans
person that I thought was kind of gross
they were selling
it was like a kids t-shirt with a trans
person on it and then they had like kids
toys with trans people on it and it was
kind of gross and groomy have you seen
anything like that before
you know I've seen t-shirts that the um
lieutenant governor of Minnesota will
protect trans kids with a knife on it
you know things like that I've seen
t-shirts that says protect trans rights
with AK-47s on it and stuff and you know
I don't think that's helpful messaging
for and that's just trans activists by
the way Ethan this is a small number of
people and that's where I'm calling out
that's who gays against groomers are
calling out it's not the trans Community
as a whole specific trans activists who
have highlighted um sorry I've hijacked
the trans movement
so actually you know what's interesting
Ollie if you go to your website right
now your merch website I was actually
talking about your merch you are
actually selling kids lunch boxes with a
picture of you depicted as a trans woman
and you're selling no that's not a trans
woman oh that's not a trans woman that's
just a K-pop picture of me
okay because this is you I I had a
feeling you would say that because here
it is you wearing that design
and it's pretty obvious to tell that
this is depicting you this is from just
like a month ago and this is when you
were trained yeah so do you think it's
appropriate to sell this to kids
well it's a lunch box with a picture of
a K-pop cartoon there's nothing like a
trance it's you as a trans woman
it's me it's a K-pop Star it's nothing
to do with being trans or not that's
just the cartoon of me as a K-pop Star
so it's not but that's not inappropriate
right but at the time you were a trans
woman
correct at the time I was a trans woman
but there's nothing inappropriate if you
as a trans woman
that I was a trans woman at the time
that picture does not depict me as a
trans woman it depicts me as a K-pop
Star but I find that interesting that
you're willing to uh
make that separation when you're making
such General claims about the groomers
and stuff because to me by your own
definition this is pretty groomy and
even if you go and this is well hold on
hold on one sec even if you go on your
website right now you're selling the
same graphic un Ali London Ali merch
Squad as you depicted as a trans woman
and if you look at the available sizes
it's just kids three to four do you
think it's appropriate for a three to
four year old to buy this shirt
yeah of course any K-Pop fan if they
want to buy my merch they're absolutely
entitled to there's nothing
inappropriate with that match at all
that is a trans woman Ollie you're not
understanding you're
clutching at straws
okay hold on let's let's follow this
through you were a trans woman when you
made this there's a picture of you
wearing it it's obviously you as a trans
woman here's you as a trans woman and
here's you as a trans woman on the shirt
on a kid's shirt how am I clutching at
straws
but you're clutching at stores there's
an innocent cartoon it doesn't say
anything about indoctrines
the tongue is out like that it's a
little disturbing
I'm cook Ethan come on I'm doing a K-pop
pose that's you're just clutching at
straws no why is the tongue out I find
that a little uh provocative
Ethan it's the cartoon you're just
trying to trying to make it well I don't
know because you're well well no I'm not
trying to make a joke I think this is a
somewhat serious issue to resolve here
because if you no I'm being serious
Ollie because let's at least be
consistent if we're going to accuse
people of grooming kids you know and
which you have made a a short lived but
uh uh somewhat profitable career of
doing then I think we need to uh you
know uh we need to get on top of this uh
I just don't think it's appropriate to
be selling lunch boxes if that lunch box
if Ethan if that lunchbox had something
inappropriate or sexual that would be
wrong but this is an innocent cartoon of
me doing a K-pop pose there's nothing
wrong with that particular picture if it
was an appropriate in a sexual way that
would be completely wrong and of course
I would never sell that but that's an
innocent drawing of the cartoon Ethan
do you think it's appropriate for a drag
queen for kids to buy let's say a kid's
at a drag queen show that's grooming
and let's say they are selling lunch
boxes to the kids of a drat with a
picture of a drag queen on it doing a
cute pose or whatever right not sexual
but they're in Drag
do you think it's appropriate for a kid
to carry that lunchbox
well I think it's appropriate for kids
at a drag show that's inappropriate
because some drag shows are generally
not inappropriate
okay that's interesting so some drag
shows are appropriate and some aren't
correct it's about doing some no correct
it's about if you're going to do
anything in front of kids it should be a
PC it should not have anything sexual
but sadly a lot of these shows are doing
sexual things so kids should not be
there if the match is there and it's a
show that's sexual they shouldn't be
there in the first place okay this is
interesting so you're saying it is okay
for kids to go to drag shows
I'm not saying that at all I don't think
they should in general but if they're
not sexual and I would assume it's not
because it's for kids right I mean if
they're doing sexual stuff I would
consider that obviously everyone would
consider that uh inappropriate but I
believe you've just said drag shows are
uh safe
for kids in fact you would either be
okay well hold on you would even you
even said you'd be okay with them
carrying a drag show lunch box
now look I just don't think kids should
be anywhere that is putting ideas into
their heads you know if a show is
innocent you know that's obviously
better than it being a sexual show but I
still don't think it should be exposed
to gender ideology
box you're selling to kids
that has nothing to do with any kind of
ideology it's a K-pop picture so yeah
but you're in drag in the picture you're
you're you are I mean you're you're
trans well you're trying I'm sorry yeah
you're right you're not in drag without
I misspoke you're trans you're a woman
you're expressing yourself as a woman on
the box
I'm just it's just a cartoon Ethan I
don't know why you keep going on about
it's just a cartoon I mean I feel like
you're trying to downplay the
significance of this Ollie I I just
afraid that some of your uh some of the
people that you associate with might
consider this Grooming by your own uh
standard I'm just looking out for you
and your reputation
it's an innocent cartoon if it was an
inappropriate picture that would be
wrong okay what do you make of this
picture these kids and are these kids in
danger your thoughts
well I haven't seen the video of that
particular show and it depends what book
They're reading if the drag queen it
appears to be depicting some fish
it's a couple of fish in the ocean it
seems like that's the rainbow fish The
Rainbow Fish uh it seems to be the
rainbow fish Ali
well it you know I think a lot of these
books are pushing even subtle messages
on gender ideology trying to tell kids
you should Tran be trans and become LGBT
and kids should make that decision on
their own so if that book is teaching
them about you know transitioning or
becoming a drag queen that's
inappropriate fish
yes but I haven't read the book I can't
see what the book Is So based on that
one picture does that book contain
subtle messaging that's trying to tell
kids to change their gender when they
shouldn't be thinking about things like
that and you know in Florida they've
obviously banned books um in the
classroom that teach gender ideology and
there's a lot of books uh kids books
there's a book called The Gay ABCs and
that pushes gender ideology from for
two-year-olds it's two plus and I don't
think that's appropriate for a kid that
just should be reading kids books that
are completely innocent they shouldn't
eat what do you think of this what do
you make of this lunch box though
but why did you keep going back to the
lunch box well because because you know
it's got a picture of a trans woman on a
kid's lunchbox
got a picture of a K-pop Star on The
Lunchbox who's the K-pop Star
who's the king
yes and this K-pop Star is a trans woman
right
I was trans at the time the image
doesn't necessarily depict anything so
you're saying did the photo of you uh uh
so not even even it's not even a photo
of me it's literally a cartoon that had
an anime cartoon drawn with me right
yeah
right
um sorry
would you buy it for your kids I mean I
I wouldn't just because I don't want to
support you financially but uh but
theoretically I I don't think I'd have a
problem with no I wouldn't have a
problem with my children uh uh looking
up to a trans person of course not what
would be wrong with that and I and and
even look I don't have a problem with
trans people at all I'm just saying that
certain things when it comes to gender
identity if
transgenderism is being pushed on young
kids in preschool or even elementary
school when they shouldn't be thinking
about that I think it's wrong to expose
them to that I think
they are exposing them to training like
this lunch boxes
right you're really obsessed with that
lunchbox no but I think it's a really uh
important point that you're not you know
coming to terms with we're exposing kids
to a trans woman don't you think that's
wrong
why is it still on your website at least
you know
you know it's it's come on even I don't
know what to say it's a cartoon of a
K-pop Star and it's very innocent it's
just like a little anime drawing it's
nothing you know if I was doing
something inappropriate if I had you
know protect trans kids on there that
would have a message that would have a
loaded gender ideology message but it
literally says Ollie's Squad with a
cartoon of me doing the peace sign it's
like super cute super innocent just like
most K-pop stars are like super cute you
know there's nothing wrong with that I
mean aren't you making like the he the
hego face a little bit
well do you think I should make it more
masculine no the hego face is like some
kind of hentai thing isn't it
I have no idea that's when it washes
your eyes and stick out your tongue
oh really but my eyes don't worry about
that
my eyes are wide open but I don't know
you don't know about the ego face
no I don't believe you come on now I
watch anime like I watch attack of the
titans straight out my brother
this is it and you can see the
resemblance right here's the aigo face
it's from it's like a hentai reference
okay but you see the resemblance right
can you put them side by side sure yeah
I'd be happy to
I mean that's quite a cute drawing right
but that's like a woman like orgasming
is what that is well or like it's like a
lustful kind of uh sexual gratification
you're really clutching I'm honestly
like I've got my eyes open I'm doing the
peace sign I'm just trying to dissect it
and say this honestly
right it just seems to me that even as a
trans person it you shouldn't be
exposing kids to that it seems like
you're shoving gender ideology down kids
throats by selling them a lunch box with
a trans woman on it
you
know if it
if it be your point completely if for
instance it had a messaging on there
like some political because I don't
think it should be exposed to politics
either um no political or gender
ideology message if that was on there
that would be different if it was a
sexually suggestive image but this is
literally an innocent cartoon I've got
my eyes open I'm doing the peace sign
you could not get in what do I need to
do even like to please people do I
actually like close my eyes well I
personally don't necessarily have a prop
what is your fascination with the eye
wideness I haven't said anything about
that
about about what sorry you said what do
I have to close my eyes I didn't know
what that meant you kept mentioning
about like the uh eye wideness of how
wide it is I don't know why you keep
bringing that up no I'm just saying that
look in the picture my eyes it's got
very it's not even me by the way it's a
cartoon but the eyes are very wide open
like ugly I'm just saying like what's
wrong with having my eyes open like
we're human beings we have to have our
eyes
I don't know I don't know what that
means Ollie here's a reference to a
popular culture with the ahigo face it's
you know like kind of an e-girl thing
you're probably aware of that
but I'm not an eagle so I wouldn't know
yeah but you're on the internet and it's
from anime which you seem to be okay but
you know I do know I do know anime and
stuff I don't know anything to do that
pose literally I've got my mouth open
like this peace I always have my mouth
open you know like
mm-hmm sure come on let me see that
again
looks really natural when you do it
thanks yes
girl so are you so the Tran but you
identify as a male now you're not trans
we're over that
no I'm like well basically I got to a
point where I was gonna probably dive
into the surgery I was doing and you
know I was really mentally struggling um
had a lot of mental health struggles
based on a variety of issues which I
talk about in my book um from when I was
being bullied very severely as a kid
um I was always told I was like ugly or
I looked like a monster or you know I
was more feminine or I had man boobs um
so I just used to have all those things
that left me with traumas so it kind of
messed up my head and okay as an adult I
didn't deal with that in the way that I
should have I should have had therapy I
should have spoke to someone I instead
it was almost like self-harming so all
this crazy surgery was me kind of um
kind of lashing out the bullies and it
was very very destructive for me and for
other people so so you know I'm glad to
be over that do you think that people
who are bullied or at a higher chance of
becoming trans
yes definitely so um I talk about this
in my book there's a lot of studies
there was a study in Finland by the top
transgender
um Clinic that um was basically
transitioning a lot of kids and they
said around I think it's around 45 of
the kids had experienced severe bullying
so that led to their gender dysphoria
um identity but there's also the other
side your theory is that the bullying
leads to the dysphoria not the dysphoria
leading to the bully which
another I was just about to say as well
but there is also the flip side of that
where kids that are the kids are being
bullied because of their identity you
know because maybe a boy is more
feminine or a girl is more like a tomboy
so they're also being bullied for that
but in in certain um studies the one in
Finland at Tampere University they found
that there was a significant correlation
between a kid being bullied and then the
onset of their gender dysphoria coming
afterwards rather than before but you
know of course it works both ways
let's see here uh I have that theory
you're citing in front of me uh Tampa
University Finland yeah here it is let's
read the conclusion it's here there's
the abstract and everything let's see
the conclusion says gender identity
especially non-binary identity is
associated with both being bullied and
perpetrating bullying even uh when a
range of variables including internal
stress and involvement in bullying and
the opposite role are taken into account
this suggests that bullying during
adolescence may serve as a mechanism of
maintaining heteronormality
which I think what that means is that
the bullying
uh actually results in people rejecting
their transness in favor of hetero
normality I think I'm that's am I that's
so so it seems to be saying the opposite
actually what you've claimed it said do
you see what I'm referring to
heteronormality no I see that I see that
article that you know if you actually
read the full study which is the
conclusion
you can find it on the National
Institute of Healthy
yeah no this is this is the uh this is
the study it's the.gov yeah yeah this is
it uh and then this is the author's
conclusion right there I mean that's
pretty much that this is the one you're
talking about do you disagree yes but
it's look the study's also saying it's
associated with being bullied and being
um the perpetrator so it's basically
saying yes but right but the
the message this is the last sentence so
let's not let's read this together
carefully it suggests that bullying
during adolescence may serve as a
mechanism of maintaining hetero
normality
so
do we understand what that says
no I get what it's saying it's basically
saying that some of these kids that are
being bullied
um will maintain their original identity
because the bullying correct but the
study also if you read the full study
the study also speaks there's a high
correlation between there's two
different findings in the study there's
a study there's a finding that's around
45 of the kids are bullied and that
causes the gender dysphoria and there's
also part of the study which also says
like the conclusionist finding that some
of these kids are bullied because of
their gender dysphoria and it makes it
worse
if two outcomes are possible then it
doesn't seem that interesting I wonder
why you bring it up
well no re read the full study it also
talks about the correlation I mean this
is the author they wrote the conclusion
right here this is their that's that's
that's a small summary on
the author that's their conclusion
correct right but if you read it to draw
a conclusion than the author of the
study
no no I'm not saying that I'm just
saying if you I've read the full study
multiple times multinational Institute
of Health
are you do you think that if bullying
prevents people from becoming
um
according to this bowling prevents more
kids from transitioning do you believe
that we need more bullying
no I'm an advocate against bullying I
think whoever gets bullied it's so so
wrong I've been bullied myself and I'm
an advocate some results in less
transitioning than that than that
according to what you're saying is the
best outcome for these kids
no I don't I don't agree at all no kid
even if a kid is feminine or a girl is a
tomboy they should not get bullied no
one should get bullied they should be
provided with support but if somebody
wants to transition I'm not against
people transitioning I just don't think
it's right as a kid because a lot of
these kids are going through so many
issues during that time they are not in
the right frame of mind to make an
informed consent decision the child is
suicidal do you believe that they should
transition
so there's a lot of um clinics and
doctors that use this argument there's a
clinic called Kaiser permanent permanate
in California Kaiser Permanente
yes that's it thank you um yeah so
basically they have used with multiple
people that have since D transitioned
Chloe Cole and Layla
um another D transitioner they basically
told them your kids are going to commit
suicide if you don't transition them but
what they said afterwards is they
actually felt worse six months down the
line after the transition because
they've got hormones in their body
they've got puberty blockers
um
that the vast majority of people that
transition don't regret it I think it's
like 95 99 are you aware of that stuff
you don't you don't hear the cases of
the D transitions
that 99 of kids that transition do not
regret it
no I don't support that statistic I
think it's wrong because these people
from what from what Authority do you dis
disprove that statistic
well look these clinics make these
studies they don't even do follow-up
studies there's an example of it do you
not trust studies because you just told
me to read one
look what I'm saying is the gender
clinics make billions of dollars every
year their studies are skewered and
biased in a review of 27 studies
involving almost 8 000 teens in adults
who had trans transgender surgeries
mostly in Europe U.S and Canada one
percent on average expressed regret for
some regret was temporary but a small
number went on to detransition uh but
that's one percent uh that seems like a
very small amount to be uh singularly
focused on and this is 27 studies so
this is a massive kind of conclusion
right a scientific conclusion a
consensus if you would
yes but what I'm saying is there's a
clinic for instance Tavistock Clinic
which was the main clinic in the UK they
were actually exposed they were doing
studies as well they weren't
the transitioners they didn't bother to
check with the d-transition they didn't
check how the hormone about that English
one for for yeah yeah so that that one
if I recall I looked into that
um
I believe it was they you know people
say it was shut down it was actually
wasn't it um they shut down right but
still open they're making they're
actually making a bigger one so they can
serve more needs I actually so it's not
really being shut down actually
yeah yeah
so that one's actually being shut down
this year because basically the National
Health Service which is basically looks
after all the hospitals in the UK for
the government
um they actually said that there were a
lot of um ethical violations and stuff
and they also changed their policy based
on what happened at that clinic via
internal investigations they found that
many of these kids were being pushed to
transition without having checks on
their mental health and they're
basically being pushed into it and fast
track right it's significant though that
of the patience of the actual people who
they transition only one percent regret
it do you you're not acknowledging that
no I don't I I don't trust uh studies
27 studies then why did you tell me to
read this one Ollie you used studies
when it's convenient for you but you
don't when it when it goes against your
thesis I don't understand your
consistency with studies do we like them
or no
what I'm trying to say Ethan is the
gender clinics are very very powerful
do we like studies or not all studies I
like studies oh we do no I like studies
but you have to always look at bias you
know the clinic in Finland was a
transgender Clinic that made the study
so they had different findings to their
many of the clinics in America that are
saying there's a low D transition rate
but there are thousands of D
transitioners out there they're just not
sharing their stories because of fear of
being attacked and uh you know they get
abuse every single day from trans
activists so there's thousands of kids
out there that are there's 50 000 D
transitioners on their Reddit uh
subreddit Forum uh speaking about the
transition but they're scared to come
out and talk about it because they're
going to get attacked so there's a lot
of people hiding
you seem to be in denial Ali that the
vast vast majority of these people let's
say there is a bias let's say instead of
one percent it's ten percent regret it
and that's a huge deviation so I'm
giving you a lot of Doubt here
if 10 only uh regret it do you think
that on whole of the 90 who uh who don't
regret it and who had what they consider
life-changing
uh Care Health Care
why would you seek to deny them
life-changing Health Care
when they even they yeah they say this
saved my life
well even a children can't get tattoos
children can't buy cigarettes or buy
alcohol so how on Earth can they consent
to doing something they don't even
understand about we have to look at many
of these kids they don't understand they
don't think about the future like if a
kid changes their body they have gender
reassignment surgery or take hormones
they might not be able to have a baby
when they're older they don't think
about those things because they're kids
so the issue is just we shouldn't be
doing this to kids it should happen you
know as an adult they can make informed
consent but even with some of the
parents agreeing to it you know do you
know how many kids between the age of 6
and 17 went through irreversible surgery
in the United States
um I know the number Rises every year
now it will be okay several thousand so
the number of patients of children
between 6 and 17 who went through
irreversible surgery in the United
States
uh what was the year the years on that
one uh three years 2019 through uh 2021.
so this is the most comprehensive data
we have and this comes straight from the
uh
the government stats it was 250 per year
does that seem significant to you
that's completely incorrect because
there was a clinic
it's in the thousands now there's a
clinic in Oregon that's done at least 7
300 is that significant yeah a thousand
I mean we have 50 million children in
the United States do you think a
thousand is statistically significant
there's thousands and this study
probably only takes into account people
on Medicaid or Medicare there are also
the parents and patients that pay out of
pockets
let's say it's thousands is this
significantly uh significant when we
have 51 million children in the United
States between ages 6 and 17.
it's significant even because it's
growing every day if you look at any
chart or graph of um kids being
medically transitioned it's now in the
tens of thousands across the U.S uh
California has uh thousands Alone
um Florida
um before Governor DeSantis bands
there's a clinic uh Dr Gallagher who
performs at least uh five surgeries uh
five surgeries or minors every month
um so you know that's just one clinician
numbers uh is it possible to get a
reference
um Dr Gallagher is a clinic in um
Florida and she operates on minors okay
and so what is wrong with the number
going up I mean let's say it goes up
from a thousand to two thousand in the
whole United States I mean so so
obviously one would assume right Ali as
people become more educated and aware of
transgenderism and we've seen the same
thing with uh homosexuality which of
course you're you are a member of the
LGBT
Community you know um in the 50s as
being uh gay became more acceptable you
saw the numbers significantly Rising
during that time I'm sure you know that
right
yeah of course because it's became more
acceptable what is the difference
between
the hysteria that took place then about
there was you know on the right that
they're turning our kids gay that turned
out not to be true you agree uh yeah
okay so hold on to that
so now today we see the same graph going
up of trans kids
getting surgery or gender affirming care
or whatever
so why is it that you today can draw a
conclusion that was the same conclusion
the 50s that you disagree with
that trans kids are being influenced
societal to
to become trans it seems to be a glaring
contradiction logic
you know it's not just random based on
the fact that people it's easier for
people to come out these days or
identify in different ways it is a
concerted push even so there's now about
gay people
even there's now over 60 pediatric
gender clinics that have opened within
the last 15 years across the U.S they
weren't there before so they are
profiting from this they're opening
clinics because they know they can
profit so when they push you know
through popular culture or push
transitioning via Tick-Tock Trends uh
they are profiting from that so it
benefits them if society and children
are being confused and indoctrinated in
schools or via social media because they
can get more patients through your book
so
that's good but let's focus on this this
issue that I want to nail down they said
that gay kids were being influenced to
be gay you disagree with that now and
you're one of the people that says kids
are being influenced to become trans and
it's the same curve
how do you do you not why is that curve
not just the result of it becoming more
acceptable uh in society
same curve
it's a huge curve you know and it's
really in the last five years since um
Tick Tock came about we're seeing so
many there's there's about 2.2 billion
what does it matter how they become
aware of it I'm telling you it's the
same curve
what I'm trying to tell you is that
there are influences now that didn't
exist 10 years ago that are pushing kids
so for instance Tick Tock there's about
2.2 so Tick Tock is turning people trans
where back in the 50s people said it was
like rock and roll music it was movies
it was hippie movements uh that wasn't
accessible to the generation before them
I don't see the difference
what I'm saying is that kids are being
exposed to influences that they didn't
have before
sorry the same in the 50s the kids who
were coming out as gay
were also exposed to things that weren't
accessible to Generations before them
well I don't agree with that they didn't
have phones back then kids are now being
push Trends and the AI algorithm
recognizes a kid's vulnerabilities music
videos music uh you know popular music
uh yeah music music well pop music was
something that was rock and roll was
something that was new back then
so no correct and and you could also
argue that
um in the 80s more people came up
because uh you know music like George
Michael was um you know a songs about
freedom and then why are you concluding
that Tick Tock is making people trans I
don't understand the logic you just
contradicted yourself
I don't know what I'm saying is in the
last five years there is an increase in
gender clinics opening because they are
exploiting um these children that are
being pushed Trends you know there's a
lot of Lobby groups even the Human
Rights Campaign is a massive Lobby group
they're going around
tick tock
um I've struggled with gender dysphoria
for all of my life but yes but my um
identity struggles came about because I
was using social media too much you were
born in 1990 you're not that much uh
younger than me when I grew up there was
no social media I don't believe you
probably had social media until you were
in your 20s well into your 20s
yeah correct and the reason I struggled
with my identity was because of a
bullying in childhood but then I only
transitioned but bullying and childhood
we we established from
the report that you told me to read that
bullying in childhood results in less
people transitioning
I could say it again this the study you
sent me
yeah
the conclusion was that bullying results
in less people transitioning so you says
it's a result of social media
well you didn't have social media then
you said it was a result of bullying but
this study you told me to read says
bullying reduces the uh the amount of
people who who transition so so how is
it that you were trans before outside of
all these uh influences that are turning
people uh trans
well firstly I'm I'm an individual so
I'm one person so my experience is not
reflective of every single person that
become trans out there but the thing is
I became trans as an adult because I
really struggled with my identity
throughout my whole life and yes I did
get bullying every case is different as
well some people are bullied because of
their gender identity some people are
not
um so every single case is different but
the reason I became trans was you know
you know you follow my journey the
Korean stuff that was me trying to find
myself and trying to you know fit in
because I hated the way
your journey is a personal one which I
totally understand then what gives you
the right to project your personal
experience onto others
well I speak to D transitioners every
day I speak to parents I speak to women
that assumes a bias Ollie you're talking
all day to D transitioners we've also
established because we I think like
studies or I don't know if we decided
you think you said you like studies
because 27 of them made a consensus that
99 of people that transition don't
regret it so if you spend all day
talking to the one percent that do
regret it don't you believe that
underlies a bias
well no I don't believe it because I
talk I talked to all sorts of people I
talk to parents that have trans kids and
you know they're trying to navigate
through that and the general consensus
with everyone I speak to because no I
don't I'm not right-wing or left wing
I'm just very much in the center I'm
just trying to help people using my
platform to try and help people you know
the general consensus is we shouldn't be
doing this to kids and there generally
is a concerted push over the last five
years to medically transition children
if kids want to experiment if a Girl
Wants to be a tomboy you know nobody has
a problem with that you know if they
want to become trans as an adult that's
on them but the issue that I talk about
every day I talk with parents I talk
with all these D transition is when this
happens to kids that's the issue I'm
speaking about it's all about people
being trans let me ask you another
question just to Pivot a little bit
mm-hmm
I'm one of the people that would say Ali
London is
willing to do anything for attention
you have probably some kind of
I don't want to diagnose you I'm not a
psychiatrist but there is some craving
for attention clearly right good or bad
I mean you recently you said about like
Korean you said your pronouns were core
Ian you know you said you were going to
get your penis size reduced so that you
could look more you could be a more
authentic Korean I mean these are not
serious things you seem to be a
provocateur is it possible that you are
participating in this right-wing grift
because one it's making you a lot of
money and two it's getting you a lot of
attention is that possible that you
actually don't care and that your your
beliefs are empty
absolutely not so when I struggle with
my identity for years I generally was
struggling and I was lashing out at
bullies and the more the more I would
get bullied online by YouTubers and
people on Tick Tock the more I would act
crazy because I was trying to feel
validated and loved and you know it was
very healthy conservative movement has
offered you quite a uh quite an open
hand uh they're very glad to be using
you as a mouthpiece against trans people
so it must feel good to be being
accepted from somebody even if it is uh
at the detriment of many people who are
at risk trans people must feel nice
there are people supporting you
no it's nothing to do with that at all
you know I I could have easily continued
doing K-pop I could have been focused on
Tick Tock which you know I used to
really enjoy doing tips I'm not the best
singer I like to make fun entertaining
videos you know I could have stuck with
that in actual fact when I
de-transitioned I lost so many brand
deals I lost you know I lost all my
invites to New York Fashion Week I was
front row everybody comparison I mean
that's the biggest show in the world or
it was rest in peace to the goat
yeah he was the original goat but no
it's it's nothing to do with that you
know so you say it's not possible that
you are just doing this for attention if
we go back here's a recording of you
saying that you're using the BLM
movement for attention and for cameos
here listen Millions so it's basically
every time I do a music video it's like
if it's a million it's a thousand pounds
so if I just keep releasing music videos
that's like enough and then also because
I've been a lot on Twitter there's been
so many people talking about me on
Twitter because I'm supporting the black
lives matter and protests and stuff so I
had 200 000 views on the video so
because of that as well I'm getting a
lot of requests so it's just you know
I'm just staying relevant
uh in the news on TV and stuff because
you know the more exposure I have you
know if I'm trending on Twitter or
whatever on TV then the more cameos I
get so yeah just so here you say you're
supporting BLM to stay relevant and
because it gets you more cameos
have you been getting more cameos since
you went uh right wing
well firstly that audio was from a
number of years ago it was edited
deceptively by somebody that was
completely uncredible
um desperate for attention it's your
voice correct
it's my voice but it was edited
deceptively to try to make money so
what's the deception
so I'm not doing any of this what I'm
doing now is to try and help people you
know previously uh
I'm open to hearing you out how is it
deceptive I'm explaining so you know
previously I had unhealthy Behavior
Where I Was generally like thinking oh
how many likes can I get how many views
can I get because I was in a really
crazy mental health place and you know
the more surgery I would get I would
feel worse about myself so I would try
and be validated via online views and
things but in fact you know I'm like now
BLM actually no no I'm not doing it now
if I wanted to eat them
I would stick to doing tick tocks I
would stick to doing my K-pop music
you're enjoying a lot more attention
right I mean you're getting a lot of
attention right now in fact you wrote a
whole damn book about it gender Madness
but what I'm doing now is because I've
actually come to a realization that I
have had some very unhealthy behaviors
in the past and I'm trying to remedy
that you know because I can't sleep at
night when I think you know have I done
something bad have I been a bad
influence so I'm actually trying to
remedy that and devote my time so that's
what you're concerned about you're going
to be feel really bad when your next
phase comes around and you realize
the mouthpiece for uh really hateful
people even it's not a phase and I'm not
a mouthpiece for anyone I'm literally
just trying to speak up about issues
that I have finally woken up to see
what's going on in the world
that if we look at all of your different
iterations of your personality the one
consistent thing is a need for attention
well you could say that about Trisha
Paytas who was your best friend and you
used to do it well I do say that I mean
yeah I would say that about Trisha
Paytas sure
but she she had a wake-up call and then
she realized that you know she could be
an influenced drivers and she's really a
positive girl she's doing amazing things
at the moments and no I had a way for
sure was a chicken nugget I believe uh
do you do you empathize with that Ali as
a former trans person
even I'm vegetarian so I wouldn't
empathize with her baby so you're saying
you're like uh yeah and congratulations
on that we support that Ollie do you do
you believe you're like Trisha Paytas
no not at all I'm not comparing myself
to her I'm just saying that she had a
lot of identity struggles she had some
unhealthy behaviors I had some unhealthy
behaviors I struggled but I'm remedying
that now I'm working hard every day to
try and be a better person to try and
help people and that's what I'm focused
on so people can call me what they want
I'm not a mouthpiece for anyone I'm
literally trying to help him
let's pivot this came about when you
found God right you uh and you can fill
in the blanks here
um you were confused you were a
transgender woman you were selling uh
kids lunch boxes depicting a trans woman
on it that's pretty low by your own
definition and then you were walking
around and you found God you entered a
church and then you realized hey
this is a Cool vibe Maybe
well now actually before that I was
starting to go to therapy so basically I
lost a lot of my friends people thought
I was really like crazy and I was I was
very mentally unwell with all of these
different crazy identities that I
struggled with so I actually started
therapy first um and I started going to
sessions twice a week and then they
actually told me you know you need to
speak about this you need to find a
community that's accepting
non-judgmental and kindness your
therapist told you that you're not trans
no my therapist didn't tell me I wasn't
trans but they said if I'm having issues
and struggling with who I am perhaps I
should find a community that's very
welcoming and might make me feel like I
can belong you know take some time off
social media
um so they didn't tell me not to be
trans it's nothing nothing to do with
that they literally told me to try and
find myself
so you took a so you took a break off
social media
and then you took yourself your time to
find God and find your new self
I stopped you know I stopped um spending
hours and hours a day on Tick Tock um
and YouTube which was you know messing
up my mind and I actually left my phone
at home I would go to photos and then I
started going to church and maybe it
made me realize you know there's more to
life than just being online or or
whatever you know and interaction to
make a difference in this world and I've
spoken to so many people that are
concerned at the direction the world's
going in and you know if I can try and
help
um parents and help you know women and
stuff and speak up for people then you
know I can um feel good
I want to show you this clip from an
interview from Piers Morgan okay lots of
pictures here if you as a woman about
how to go was that was that
that was actually a London Fashion Week
so that was literally a month ago so
kind of a drastic change so you went
from a month you went from trans woman
at Fashion Week a month later to being
on Pierce Morgan denouncing the trans
movement when you said get off uh take
your time and talk and figure out who
you are you that all happened within a
month
now actually since I uh originally
transitioned I felt great for a couple
of months and then I really started to
question it I started to think okay I
can even do more surgery to make myself
physically become a transgender woman or
I can take a step back so I was having a
lot of thoughts of regret but it was too
late at that point I'd already done
facial feminization I'd already changed
myself I was very confused so I'd been
having those thoughts for a number of
months and then within a month from that
particular picture being taken I
actually do transitions so tell me about
finding God tell me about when you were
in the church and you
had like an Awakening
well I'd lost a lot of friends I lost a
lot of loved ones because they thought
my behavior was very unhealthy and um
you know it was a Now or Never movement
I could have continued down a very
destructive path destructive for myself
and people around me and distracted for
you know people that See Me online it's
I I think I was you know not a good role
model and I deeply regret that so
I find that interesting
no I I well at the time in my delusion I
thought I was a role model for people
that liked K-pop and wanted to be
um
so then I started going to church to try
and uh take some time out to think about
my life and think you know what is the
next step for me and then you know after
spending some time going to church
sessions and sermons it made me realize
you know just try to find acceptance
with who I am and stop doing all this
craziness and try to get back to the
real me and that's the most important
thing you I've heard you mention the
real you the real you being
uh a British man
but if you talk to other people I think
they might say the real them and as as I
think you would agree people are born
gay they don't choose to be gay do you
agree with that yes yes okay okay
so then why I agree and I believe sorry
I believe that some people generally
feel trans since they're born I do
believe that so that's so God made them
that way right so God would have made
them that way
I just believe that some people are born
as trans but my issue is kids being
indoctrinated to transition when they
didn't think about that before so
however you're born that's the way you
you feel then that's okay but I don't
believe in people that wouldn't think
about these things being indoctrinated
to change because you said you want it
because when you're on these shows you
kind of make a point about being like
I'm going back and I'm being true to
myself implying almost that like this
trans thing is just some kind of silly
uh uh you know uh psychosis you had but
you're saying now being born trans is
actually a state that God creates people
in
I'm saying that some people are born
trans God make people trans
I'm not saying anything on that on that
subject I'm just saying that some people
feel everybody feels different you know
everybody feels different wait why are
you not willing to say that God makes
people trans
I'm just I know I'm just saying that
people are born in different ways they
feel different some people might be born
into sex some people are born and they
talk about God going back to how God or
Jesus intended me so I feel like this is
an interesting point to resolve because
this is something that you bring up in
your interviews God makes people trans I
find that I find that too I never said I
never said God made people trans I never
said God didn't make people does God
make people gay
I'm just saying that people are born in
different ways because you said you were
born you were born gay and so I was born
I wasn't born I was born a man then as a
teenager I became gay
um so it didn't happen from birth but I
struggled with my I was very feminine
and I struggled with my identity uh as a
kid is that your choice or God's choice
you know there's a lot of influences
that influence people in life you know
God is all powerful right
now perhaps I wouldn't have turned out
the way I did if I wasn't bullied or
perhaps
yeah God is very powerful yes absolutely
powerful
but it's got all powerful God is all
powerful but there are so then he made
you gay and trans people trans
ition why were God all-powerful make
someone
so confused that they wanted to be trans
well actually logically it doesn't even
make sense if God is all powerful and he
creates a being
and then this being lives through their
lives and then says oh I want to
transition God made them that way they
if God is all-powerful it's all part of
his design God wants people to be trans
or there are societal environments God
created Society
yes correct but I was saying
there's a lot of even there's a lot of
human factors that God created humans
if people are yes I know that but if
people are exposed to gender ideology
ideology
what I'm saying is a lot of these people
would not have felt this way when
they're born but they're being pushed by
Society in society to think that they're
going to transition God created
society and transitioning as an
operation
I mean just tell where am I logically
wrong I don't see any logical conclusion
that doesn't come to the idea that God
made people trans
I never said God made anyone trans I
just said that society and the
environment society influence people
he's all-powerful right
you said he's all-powerful
yes God is all powerful but also humans
have influences on other humans but he
made humans
no this isn't going to be with that it's
not is it okay let's go on
um do you believe that the Bible is
against transgenderism or what's your
thought on that as a as a I guess a
newborn Christian
well you know the Bible was written um a
long time ago and there are things in
the Bible such as in the Old Testament
that aren't relevant to today's society
we know that
um so we have to adapt what was written
2000 years ago to the modern day but um
you know I'm not I'm not one for
policing how adults live their lives but
I think you know transgenderism wasn't
in the Bible because there weren't trans
people
no no look I've even got this in my book
even though it was a Roman emperor that
was trans he used to dress as a woman
um so we know there's instances but I'm
just staying in The Bible Society
the society influenced the emperor to be
trans
well I wasn't alive then well hold on I
wrote about it in your book God dang man
yes but so so there were some um Roman
Scholars that were around at the time
and taken from their writings he used to
dress as a woman he used to act like a
woman and his wife would have to call
him ma'am now I I wasn't around back
then so I don't know the exact details
but he thought he was a woman so you
know maybe he he could have been born
like that some people are born like that
and they generally think that they're in
their own body so you don't have an
opinion on if the Bible supports
transgenderism or not
even
you know the Bible was written a long
time ago yeah but but surely I mean you
know why use the Bible as a guide for
anything in your life if it was written
so long ago I don't understand that
point because Ethan because there's many
teachings in the Bible that are very
very positive uh you know about love and
acceptance and kindness
um and trying to help Humanity
um it was written a long time ago so
like I said the Old Testament there's
also a story about this like uh sisters
raping their dad
okay I like your optimism
so I'm saying the Old Testament we're
not doing the Old Testament
Okay cool so we don't okay okay I heard
you when you're on these shows I notice
you talk a lot about
um
this specific story of Jesus that
inspired you how he
helped the lepers when nobody else would
and that you in your at the time when
you found Jesus you felt like the leper
you like that's that's a nice story
well I thought it was a good analogy
because I felt like um for many years I
was rejected by Society I was treated
like an outcast just like the leper so I
thought it was a good analogy to um to
me I agree it is a really good analogy
what other Bible stories do you like
um so there's the tale of the um lost
sheep um in Luke the parable of the lost
sheep where a sheep goes missing
um from a flock of a hundred and the
shepherd decides should he stay with the
flock or should he go and help this
sheep and he actually goes into the
Wilderness to help the Sheep because he
realizes that every sheep is one of
God's children so he needs to help them
and be responsible for them
which verse was that I want to read that
one
uh it's in Luke and Matthew Luke and
Matthew do you know the
the number I can't give you the exact
chapter but you can look it up is there
any other uh uh Bible stories you like
I'm looking for good recommendations
yeah there's also when Jesus
um met a Roman officer and this Roman
office had a lot of power but instead of
you know abusing that power like many
Roman officers did he was actually kind
to his servants he had servants that
were captured um from battles and they
were working in his house but he treated
them the same he treated everyone else
so that's another great analogy that you
know Jesus looked at people and helped
people that helped other people and you
know kindness is very important
do you know the verse on that one so I
can reference it I can't quite it off
the top I don't know where that one is
where there's a lot of verses in the
Bible there's a lot of chapters but I
can tell you specific stories that I
like okay
I was just testing you ollie you know
what I mean I know I'm just trying to
test you you know I was trying to do a
fast one on you
yeah but I want to ask um
you know if we're talking about
protecting kids
it all comes down to protecting kids
right I mean this is the thesis I've
heard you explain so as a Catholic uh do
you what do you think poses a greater
threat drag shows or uh
clergy members
well actually there's a lot of scandals
and very bad things that have happened
with the clergyens you know I'm against
all forms of abuse so there's a lot that
the Catholic church has done in the past
there was even a cardinal there I
believe he died
um earlier this year an Australian
Cardinal that was accused of some
horrific things and there's it's there's
a lot of that going on as well so that
needs to be addressed and I will call
that out as well as well as calling out
drag shows that are sexualizing kids
because all forms of child abuse whether
it's in a church whether it's in a
religious organization or whatever if
you had kids would you feel more
comfortable leaving them at a drag uh
time story time or with a clergy member
you know if I had kids I would actually
be with them all the time I wouldn't
leave them anywhere you would never
leave them
no because you know as a hypothetically
you know you don't have to do it I'm
just talking hypothetically would you
leave would you feel more comfortable
leaving them with a clergy man a member
of the of the Catholic church or at the
Bible or sorry the drag queen Story Time
hour
again neither I wouldn't want to leave
and it's just a theoretical it's just
theoretical no no I I get that but I'm
just saying I would even even if it was
you know leaving it right but you have
to choose one which one do you trust
more
well I wouldn't leave my kid anyway like
I wouldn't leave the kids and I think
parents have duties right but just
theoretically which one would you choose
I'm not going to answer that because I
wouldn't I wouldn't either you wouldn't
okay let's put it this way there's a
dude named Barry he's got kids and he
goes I have no choice I have to leave my
kids either with the clergyman or at the
drag show I don't have a choice
something crazy is happening they're
right next to each other it says Ah
where do I leave my kids where do you
think Barry should leave his kids
well again I wouldn't want to leave kids
anywhere he doesn't have a choice
he doesn't have a choice he's in this
horrible person even I'm not married I
can't answer that question he's asking
you for advice quick Ollie where should
I put my kids you put me on the spot you
know I I wouldn't I as an adult
as a Catholic I find it very
concerning that you are hesitant to even
answer that question
no I'm saying it doesn't matter whether
it's a Catholic Church a drag show or
even an after-school Club where it's you
know the teachers aren't present I
wouldn't leave the kid anyway I wouldn't
leave the kid at some weekend activity
like a sports activity I think the
parents should always be there
right so it's not a question of a church
versus
um you know whatever it's a question of
just in general parents should always be
with their kids but that's not
reasonable parents can't always be with
their kids I mean that's no no of course
of course it's not always reasonable but
I'm just saying in an ideal scenario you
know because look there are cases that
that happen many cases that don't happen
but I'm just saying it's you've always
got to be careful because there are
people out well let's assume that you're
a good Christian and you say I'd leave
them uh with the Catholic Church we've
talked about the number of kids who are
doing irreversible transitioning in
America it's very very small we're
talking like
250 a year by my estimate
and that's based on government data I
know you you uh dispute it you know
there's a recent report that came out in
France and the reason I bring this one
up is just because it's the most recent
and comprehensive one it's quite quite
disturbing uh this came out I believe in
called The Independent Commission of on
sexual abuse in the church it was a huge
government uh uh commission to look at
this openly and honestly and try to
figure out what's going on uh 2 900
and 3200 clergy members were involved in
sexual abuse of minors during that
period in France okay
um it's estimated that they abused
around 330 000 kids
now if you do a percentage of that and
this is really kind of surprising to me
and tell me what you think
assuming they're around fifteen thousand
to twenty thousand clergy members in
France
at any given time the percent of the
percentage of clergy men involved in
abusive minors would be 15 to 20 percent
yeah that's absolutely horrifying and
also there's in Ireland as well there
was a lot of abuse that was covered up
and no it doesn't matter it seems like
that affects more kids
that is equally wrong whoever exposes
kids it doesn't matter whether it's a
church or not being a kid is equally as
wrong as going to a drag show
look it's equally wrong if someone
abuses a kid so that's what I'm saying
here so if a kid is being abused is
there any history of a child being
abused at a drag show
when when drag shows are sexually
explicit is that the same as raping them
that is also child abuse I'm just saying
if a drag queen performs a sexually
explicit act in front of the kids that
is abuse if we're worried about the kids
we're looking you're a member of an
organization which by my estimate which
again is just an estimate but 15 to 20
percent of the clergy members
are sexual predators why is it that
you're focused on the drag shows and not
the Catholic church when per capita and
the volume is way more in the Catholic
Church
or the specific organization gazed
against groomers is focused solely on
the issue of indoctrination children
exposing them to sex if it was called
you know Catholics against groomers that
would be focused on that issue but it's
a specific issue not every organization
can focus on every issue but their uh
job is to expose a specific issue within
a specific group and granted like you
said there are in France there was an
island some horrific cases and you know
it's the job of the Pope and the
Catholic Church to vigorously
investigate that because it's disgusting
for any person uh whether a clergy
member or not to abuse a child is
absolutely wrong and it should be
investigated to the full and every
single victim it just deserves just a
little disingenuous when you're gonna
Point let's say
you've got the whole hotel a whole
building it's on fire but you know
across but in the backyard there's like
a dog house that's on fire there's no
dog in it by the way it's just a small
structure and you're telling the fire
department we need to put out the dog
house fire don't worry about the [__]
massive apartment building that's on
fire let's put out the dog house to me
that seems like you're focused on the
wrong thing what's the point of focusing
on the doghouse when the you know the
whole building is on fire right
well no I mean I talk up on my Twitter
about all forms of abuse if there's
somebody that abuses a kid you know if
there's a news story I do share on that
so but I'm just saying the specific
organization gaze against Grimace
focuses on a specific subject but you're
right all forms of abuse are incredibly
wrong and they should also get uh light
shed on them 100 are you interested in a
firearm deaths of kids because that's
the leading death actually of kids in
America today
yeah that's absolutely horrific what we
what we see every day with schools being
shut up it's absolutely horrifying
right but somehow the draft shows
children to be you know even we're on
the same page I just don't understand
why the drag show is more pertinent
because you're doing a tour right you're
doing all the right Wings you even wrote
a book for Pete's sake called gender
Madness why is this topic
um so important when we're talking about
protecting kids and there's just these
incredible the more pertinent issues uh
you know firearm deaths
the leading cause of death in kids and
you're talking about an organization
with 15 to 20 percent of sexual
predators by my estimate I just don't
understand the focus on the drag show
don't you think that the conservative
movement is overly focused on
transgender issues
foreign
there are so many different issues in
the world and you know I'm trying to
focus on one specific issue that we have
seen a rise in the last few years a very
shocking rise you know but equally the
issue of kids in schools that is
horrific every kid should be protected
and safe going to a school just like if
a kid is at a church they should be
protected no child should be uh getting
abused but you know I'm specifically
focused on one subject right now because
you know I've struggled with gender
ideology I've seen the trend this is my
it's like the whole right winged uh
apparatus is focused on that isn't that
odd I mean it just seems odd that the
entire right-wing apparatus is focused
on trans issues do you find that odd why
are they all so focused on trans issues
well I mean I talk about a lot of other
issues as well but what's happening at
the moment is there is a lot of um right
they talk about a lot of issues but I
think we can all agree that that is uh
that's kind of the most pertinent for
them right even important yeah even in
polls people say the trans trans issues
is the most important to them of
conservatives why is that well I mean I
mean correct because it is a very um big
subject right now because we're seeing
you know every day these um news stories
of of children with horrific um stories
that gender clinics we're seeing you
know drag queens uh not all drag queens
like I said but we're seeing drag shows
where they're doing very sexually
explicit things and it's become a real
recent phenomenon in the last few years
and it's rising every day so the reason
conservatives speak up is because it's a
rising issue they're trying to counter
it before it gets even more out of hand
because you know we're seeing some very
sad things the Nashville police still
haven't released the manifesto but when
uh Audrey hell initially shut up that
school they said that uh gender the
person's gender ideology may have played
a role they believed there was
absolutely because I mean a lot of the
well have I mentioned that you're
selling a lunchbox with a trans woman on
it I don't think you mentioned it Ethan
no I don't think you said it at all
actually
okay so how do you just if I ever
mentioned it how do you justify this
oh we have talked about it okay
okay I'm just curious let me look at the
photos
I mean this is definitely for kids it's
pretty small I can't even fit like a
little bread in it barely and like look
I mean these blueberries like Monsters
next to that that's certainly for kids
right yeah
it's too small
what's that no it's for anyone anyone
who likes K-pop for anyone that likes
K-pop but grown-ups I mean my God what
are they eating for lunch five
blueberries
why would you do that
it's a K-pop it's an image of a K-pop I
would buy it because it's cute you know
I like Kpop stuff I love Korean culture
it's a cute Kpop lunch box
but clearly you're not going to be
buying it well not just because I don't
want to support you financially like I
said have you seen uh Bella delphine's
new merch uh interestingly uh it looks
quite similar to what you're selling
that's obviously you've just Photoshop
that oh wait how dare you accuse me of
that
excuse me I'll let you know that's
defamation
kind of obvious because it's just a
league Squad do you think the New
Testament is uh child appropriate
yeah there's a great teachings in the
Bible that it's all about kindness and
um Roman uh 126 to 27. for this reason
God gave them up to dishonorable
passions for their women exchanged
natural relations for those that are
contrary to Nature and the men likewise
gave up natural relations with women and
were consumed with passion for one
another men committing Shameless acts
with men and receiving in themselves the
due penalty for their error why is it
that you feel entitled to be gay
sorry like I said earlier this book was
written you know a long time ago where
um ideologies were different we can't
play that game where you pick and cheats
you can't interpret every single line
and take it as gospel you have to choose
the bits that are relevant to modern
society under the relevantages
you're just gonna pick the ones you like
I thought God's word was infallible you
can't be like Yo God I love you and
you're infallible and all but this one
it's a little outdated
is
Ethan just like with other textbooks
from religions like the Quran people
interpret it differently
Timothy 1 9 through 110 says
understanding this the law is not laid
down for the just but for the Lawless
and disobedient for the ungodly and
sinners for the Unholy and profane and
for those who strike their father and
mothers for murderers the sexually
immoral men who practice homosexuality
enslavers liars purgers and whatever
else is contrary to sound Doctrine
yeah
what about Corinthians 6 9 or do you not
know that the unrighteous will not
inherit the kingdom of God do not be
deceived neither the sexually immoral
nor idolators nor adulterers nor men who
practice homosexuality nor thieves nor
the greedy nor drunkards nor revilers
nor swindlers were inherent the kingdom
of God there's a lot of lines that speak
against homosexuality but not a lot of
lines to speak against transgender so
why is it that
transgender you should be more concerned
about the fact that you are a homosexual
that seems to be a great sin
well again like I told you you don't
have to interpret every single thing but
there's around the Bible because there's
like a lot of people Society lines see
this was written in that time Society
okay let me ask you this then what's the
difference every single word but you can
choose parts of the Bible that are
relevant to you and the modern society
and learn from them like kindness which
is a very important message
do you think it's kind to tell a
suicidal child that they can't
transition
um
did he bail or is that us
oh
is that us
uh checking
I don't think he bailed
uh a [__]
do we have internet
yes
are we live
I hope so
uh he's still he's still in the zoom but
are we
I mean our internet works right
yeah
I just disconnected oh so he's gone
oh you're back okay good thank you yeah
the Wi-Fi is gone but I do have to go
soon Ethan because let me ask you this I
understand thank you for spending so
much time with us you're welcome you say
you learned to be kind in the Bible do
you believe it's kind to tell a suicidal
a child that they can't transition
no but I think adults have a
responsibility to help that child's
mental health support so whether that's
therapy if a child if a child is
suicidal do you believe it's okay for
them to transition
well the problem with what you're saying
is that's the argument that many gender
clinics use to coerce parents to
transition their kids but you actually
have to treat the real issues which is
maybe the kid is suffering from
depression or they have struggles with
others issues no but this is a real
issue kids are suicidal because of their
gender dysphoria I mean that's a real
issue
but even what I'm trying to say is if
you put a vulnerable kid that's already
struggling with the mental health on
very high doses of hormones or puberty
blockers
before they decide uh that's after they
decide this kid is is suicidal the only
way to save their life as you hear from
a lot of people is to uh help them
transition
what is wrong with that
no correct you hear that a lot but you
yes
as a child transitioning ever saved a
child's life
or you need to address the mental health
issues of the kids life
uh transitioning yeah
yes of course there will be case as well
so if it's saved even one child's life
then where do you get off preventing
this from happening you say one child's
all that matters if you can admit to me
the transition a child transitioning
saved their life even one of them
why would you support a movement that
Outlaws it
support legislation that makes it
illegal why is that because firstly
these are kids they cannot consent to
this they don't want to save their land
the long-term consequences but you don't
look at what happens a lot later down
the line
we got to stick on this point you said
that transitioning has saved a child's
life
let's forget about all the other steps
let's forget about all the other static
why is it that you would want to outlaw
a a medical procedure that saved a
child's life
that's not kind is it
no you have to support the kids mental
health but you cannot put them on
hormones do you believe that it should
be illegal do you believe that should be
illegal for kids to transition
I believe for medical transitions it
should be 18 plus yes even if the kid is
going to kill himself as you admitted
the kid it saved the child's life you
said that so
so you believe this kid should kill
themselves rather than transition
absolutely not don't try to put words in
my mouth
no hey I'm not trying to put any words
in your mouth I'm just trying to
reconcile you are saying on one hand
that transitioning saved the kid's life
and also saying that transitioning
shouldn't be allowed until they're 18
plus so this child has no recourse other
than to kill themselves in this
hypothetical situation we've created
this hypothetical situation instead of
that actually take the kids um to
somewhere that's a safe place where they
can be surrounded by friends they do
that but again I don't want to focus on
the static because this is a real
situation and let's say even if it's
just one kid
again
let's let's stay focused here Ollie one
kid saved his life you're telling that
kid you cannot get that procedure that's
correct
I'm saying that kids can't consent to
this kids need better mental health
support so they should be a focus on 18
minutes you're saying this kid cannot
get that procedure that saved his life
that's what you're I'm saying that it
should I'm saying that 18 plus for all
procedures on kids because kids cannot
consent so they need mental health
support instead well kit right so the
kid would kill himself
no you give the kids then why did you
say that it saves kids lives Ollie don't
you understand that you're not making
sure
I'm saying that there will be some kids
that may feel better and feel like
they're like no no no no no no they use
agreed with me Ollie just a few minutes
ago that transitioning has saved kids
lives
or like like anything in life it can
save lives but also a lot of people like
anything in life what does that mean a
thing well a lot of people will become
suicidal later down the line because
their body is completely messed up um
they're you know so many different
issues with their health
um that they're not being informed about
so it's about 99 don't regret it
no I'm just saying that it's informed
consent kids can't consent
kids can't consent to anything what are
we doing we're not allowing them to kids
can't consent to go to church kid can't
consent to go to school kids can't
consent to anything we we as parents
make the best decision we can for the
welfare of the kid don't you agree I
mean this whole idea of consent is kind
of moot when you consider all the things
kids do in their life in their lives
every day
oh it's like a little kid that wants to
be a dinosaur do you suddenly give him a
surgery do you think they're wanting to
be a dinosaur is is uh comparable to a
gender dysphoria which is a known
medical condition
I'm saying that some people said it's
like kids wanting to be dinosaurs I
don't understand the comparison
well no it is it's like some kids change
their mind about certain things they're
not mature enough to make these
decisions do you think wanting to be a
dinosaur is comparable to being a trans
I'm saying if a 10 year old kid
addresses up as a dinosaur every day
they tell their dad they're uh that
happened can you uh cite that happening
you've been speaking about free radical
things I'm speaking about no no no no no
well we're talking about theoretical
integration talking about theoretical
situations but they are real happening
in the real world there are kids whose
lives are being saved because and this
is the small amount of kids who undergo
it very small amount that do it under
doctors supervision and panels and stuff
that it's saving their lives this is
happening okay people are not I don't as
far as I know maybe you can correct me
saying I'm a dinosaur I need to
transition into a dinosaur
yeah I'm saying yeah the kids want
different things they don't understand I
notice you're saying I'm saying a lot
you say things but you don't like to uh
stay accountable to it you say no I'm
saying this you know I'm saying this no
I'm saying this why won't you give me
definitive answers
well I'm I'm equating it you know what
it is the same if a child wants to be a
dinosaur you don't come up there okay
it's the same body part it's the same
the same as being gender same as
medically transitioning
oh good I'm glad you said that gender
dysmorphia is a known medical condition
is there any literature about
transitioning to be a dinosaur
not that you know right but you said
it's the same but clearly it's not right
because
accelerator
sorry I'm equating a kid identifying in
a different way you don't just suddenly
say if a kid feels a certain way oh
we're gonna do this operation we're
going to give you hormones
that doesn't happen
you have a child who's experiencing
gender dysmorphia so severe that they're
going to kill themselves
dysphoria excuse me they're undergoing
panels and doctors and stuff and this
kid we know and this has happened either
we intervene
or the child kills themselves what's
your decision
most kids grow out agenda that's not
what I asked why can't you answer most
kids do not grow at a gender just uh
this uh dysmorphia not only 99 oh that's
a small number of them and 99 who get
the operations uh don't regret it you
have to answer this Ollie this is
important if there's a child that's
going to kill itself unless it gets
uh gender affirming care what is your
decision
let's study give them the decision give
them the give them the treatment or not
no you give them mental health support
instead you do not no no no no no no no
no that's not what I am asking do if
this kid is suicidal which is a known
phenomenon this happens
do you let them get the treatment or do
you make them wait till they're 18.
you give them other support instead so
they kill themselves
how is it how is that kind that you're
letting children's kill themselves
instead of letting them get gender
life-saving care which by the way
happens only irreversible gender care uh
gender surgeries and stuff only happens
like 250 times a year no it doesn't it
happens well you have no statistics to
back that up
well there's a clinic in Oregon I can
send you the statistics itself there's a
clinic in Oregon that does at least 300
surgeries on kids a year so that's just
one Clinic that's not true there's 60
there's 60 clinics in the US that are
people over years over years yeah 60
over years
so but again there's 50 million kids in
America Ali that's not a lot
but I'm saying there's 60 gender clinics
that are performing these surgeries
every single week across the country so
look it up and let's see let's say that
of the Thousand there's ten kids who are
going to kill themselves
do we let them get this treatment or not
again you give the kids mental health
support you're choosing for them to kill
themselves Ollie no I'm not trying to
say that because but you are but that's
what you're saying Ollie I'm not saying
that is what you're saying if you're
denying them life-saving gender
affirming care
no I'm saying give the kids mental
health support yeah you're selling
you're not this Avenue that doesn't work
that's not going to work to prevent you
from killing yourself
you're telling them you cannot have the
anecdote that's going to save your life
you can only do the therapy that I
approve of you can only do the therapy
that I say is okay for you ollie you
went through this whole gender
transition why do you deny people the
journey that you yourself had
because I had that Journey as an adult
and even though I regret it I was an
adult but kids cannot consent so I'll
say it again kids can't consent to
anything kids can't consent to anything
but even this is irreversible we're not
just no it's not sometimes it's not most
of the times it is reversible
and and when it's not reversible it's
done under extreme care under doctor
supervision you want this kid to kill
themselves Ollie how do you live with
that how do you betray the community the
trans community that you're a part of
you sold yourself out for some attention
and some money and you're you're you are
dooming kids to kill themselves how do
you live with that before it was cute
silly stuff about trans-racial and BTS
and pop stuff and it was just silly
nonsense about uh rate little racist
stuff about Korean people having tiny
penises but now you're you're actually
delving into
transphobic violent transphobia that is
going to result in kids dying you're
gonna have to reckon with that Ollie
no absolutely not you're trying to paint
me out as saying this understanding what
you said
to anything
because he has leg cancer should you be
able to get the leg removed
well if he has the cancer yes okay so
what's the [__] difference he can't
consent to have his leg removed that's
irreversible
well many of these kids are being pushed
into it many grow out to gender
dysphoria if you Google right but I'm
telling you kids kill themselves if they
don't get this treatment in the rare
case that it's that severe about 250 a
year or show me okay pull up a pull up a
case then I'm sure we can do that that's
not a problem give me one second
gender affirming care is mental health
support
right there are otherwise
the the American Institute of Psychiatry
and kids Health Pediatrics they all
agree
that the correct care for children with
dysmorphia is gender affirming care do
you know more than Pediatrics
Association and psychiatrist Association
they made 2.2 billion dollars uh
transitioning kids last year so it's a
multi-billion dollar industry with a lot
of power so people make so people make
money from it so therefore we shouldn't
let kids save them their lives
no you can provide I'm not going to keep
going on about the same thing you can
provide kids with the right mental
health support that doesn't include
putting them on harmful hormones that
can cause irreversible issues and when
they you're right we should make it free
you're right people shouldn't be charged
for it
no no
I'm just not going to keep going on
about the same thing Ethan I'm gonna I
need to go anywhere it's quite late
Ollie
I want to tell you something
you really have sold your soul in this
one you know what I mean like before it
was cute but this new one is really sick
and I mean the goals of you to sell a
[__] lunch pail with a trans person
on it while telling people that they're
grooming kids I mean you're just a
[__] hypocrite dude
if an use that's horrific comments about
Ben Shapiro saying that he should be
gassed making the Holocaust but you
shouldn't be I didn't say that I said
I'll tell you exactly what I said and
how dare you say such a
he's perpetuating anti-Semitism and
therefore if there's another
you know then I then he can go you know
and uh I'd be happy to I'd be happy to
go right behind him I am Jewish though
so chill out no I know that but I'm just
saying it's not something to joke about
so you know when you're trying to
criticize for me for certain things you
know you've also said some things that
are very harmful as well hold on to take
accountability so you're admitting that
what you say about trans people is
offensive no I'm talking about
I'm talking about my past behaviors you
know have been harmful and I'm talking
about your past behavior I'm talking
about what you're doing now that
endangers children because you're trying
to make it
now no I'm helping people leave them
you're helping Tucker Carlson spread
propaganda that's gonna kill trans
people and you're selling a book called
gender Madness after you TR how long
have you been a oh how long have you
been a man how long have you been
detransitioned and you're writing a book
already
it's been seven months seven months
Ollie I mean you were trans for years
how are you gonna spend seven months as
a man and then presume to tell people
how to live their lives that's doesn't
even make sense Ollie how dare you uh
seven months that's not that's not
enough time to give me an informed
decision about what it means to
transition
especially when you lived as a trans
person for so long
yeah but the book is about my how I got
to where I was what led me to that and
how people struggle with different
identities it's actually a self-help
book so it's very positive empowering
amount of different ways people can help
themselves gender Madness here's your
best friend Jamie Mitchell who's the
founder of uh gays against groomers uh
saying uh
supporting um
well here just watching now would make
you know I think Joseph Mengele uh I
believe that was his name you know the
Nazi doctor
um he you know this puts him to shame
they're do you believe that's an
appropriate analogy
well Joseph Mengele tortured and uh
performed medical horrific medical
procedures on kids you know
Holocaust he also uh he also committed a
genocide against trans people by the way
he committed a genocide against trans
people as well
let's be consistent they are basically
using an entire general how dare you
question of children as Lab Rats for
this sick ideology
um
right now
um and a threat to that you've been very
open about you know your conservative
voice as well is it is it hard to be uh
you know to have a conservative voice
now
uh yeah I mean I am personally
conservative I've actually had an online
presence as the gay who straight on
Instagram primarily for over six years
um and we do you believe that doctors
are performing nazi-like uh experiments
on trans kids
doctors are experimenting on kids to
what end what is an experiment
any medical mutilation on kids is bad
and you know underlies a thesis what is
their thesis
I'm saying there's no long-term data on
how does this affect yes there is 99
don't regret it
how does this affect a kid 20 years down
the line because they're happy issues 99
are happy
we see issues
look at the study by Dr Bradley Canadian
she was the Pioneer for uh performing
these gender affirming cares on kids
what if I told you that Dr Bradley was a
quack
well they're all cracks anyone that
experiments on kids in the first place
is the quack all right Ollie we're gonna
anyway thank you for uh spending your
time I do appreciate you coming on
all right it's good to talk it was it
was uh it was something
but I I you know uh I do think that
since God created God created trans
people you know what I mean and uh when
when uh you know kingdom come you're
gonna have to answer for what you're
doing this is not kindness
Jesus does not hate to trans kids
Jesus doesn't hate anyone but you know
what I've been saying throughout the
interview and you know we've we've spoke
about this already is it's I'm simply
speaking up about we shouldn't do this
to kids I know you're trying to make the
argument that this can lead to it's not
happening to kids it's 250 a year
it's not 200. you're just making that up
that's [__] no you can look on
Google I've looked up every single thing
you've said I fact checked every single
thing you said it's all propaganda it's
all lies
dismantled every single point you have
but you can look at Dr Gallagher in
Miami and see how many operations she
does on kids that's just one Clinic
there are 60 clinics plus that are doing
this so imagine every single Clinic
added up they're profiting from this
it's seventy thousand dollars they make
for my girls London who is uh in favor
of kids killing themselves thank you for
calling
but that's even funny to joke about
things like that why am I joking my
friends
Ethan I've been talking about mental
health support that's the real issue
here we need to help people with their
struggles and not be putting them on
medication you know uh early London
wrong with favor of kids uh killing
themselves if um Ethan not cool right
anyway thank you for your time well it
is not cool actually that's putting it
mildly it's actually demand no it's not
cool that you're trying to say that I'm
Pro foreign
no it's not it's about I've been saying
about we need to give mental health
support instead of putting all of these
kids gender information mental support
will agree to disagree and um Good Luck
okay you're a demon
have a good night
wow
well done
hold on I don't know I don't know if we
got anywhere with him because we didn't
get anywhere with him but because he's
like he's pretty slippery you know he's
smarter or more prepared I would say
he's like media trained unlike Sebastian
or or uh or uh have a good night or have
a good night guy uh Nexium dude have a
good night yeah yeah because he's he's
got this media training that they're
slippery but the man is selling a
[__] lunchbox with a trans person
you can bring the chat back absolutely
crazy okay I'm gonna turn the chat back
on y'all y'all are free uh one second I
don't know I tried but you tried you
tried but he's too invested I mean he
like you said he's he's in he's in that
world now he's on that circuit he's on
going on oan and Newsmax and all this
[__] Tucker Carlson he's telling a book
it's it's he's in way too deep
but I will tell you I don't know if it
would ever get to them but there were
quite a few sound bites in there that
his new friends did not appreciate
that's what I'm saying like do your new
friends know all this stuff about you
ollie I mean Tucker Carlson would would
be really interested to know that you're
selling lunch boxes with a trans even to
something as simple as uh oh the Bible
it's okay it it's old and it's okay to
reinterpret it for modern times I mean
the evangelicals that I mean we're
talking about fundamentalists here they
believe they're not pro-game
invaluability of the Bible that's that's
yeah we don't we don't mess with that
that's God's word
that's God's word y'all yeah I think you
hit it the nail on the head with it he
will do anything and say anything to be
famous yeah that is what it comes down
to
um it's he's spewing this hatred this
dog [__] this [__] just in the name
of Fame you know
for a drip of clout I hope that my hope
in this was that we can at least
damage his reputation with his new
friends
I I kind of feel like it might go the
other way you might have just
alley-ooped him a little bit with his
friends I feel like
I understand what you're saying but at
the same time he has the same points
that he repeats time after time I feel
like now he has some other [__] to talk
about yeah maybe it just depends on how
it's uh selectively edited you know
right
Hassan's Chad was loving you they were
very impressed I mean like dude you're
not actually chimed in he sent a message
in the middle of that asking us to pull
up the bad Bible stories but you had
already asked us to do it we were he had
the same thought and like hit him it's
just a crazy ass Bible quotes it's just
not safe for kids the New Testament
really not it's grooming as [__]
yeah
oh here oh I wish I saw this before but
here's a clip of him who's Ali London
it's called Ollie that one this man has
a compilation of people saying his name
that he uploaded himself on his [__]
YouTube channel including you the only
only one Ollie London an influencer and
popsicles
I don't I know it's not related but this
is the strangest looking man I've ever
seen in my life I thought it was edited
it's marked Meats she's just British
London
Ali London Ali London London talking
about groomers and putting James Charles
in your compilations flooded with Holly
London Ollie London Ollie London Ollie
London Ollie London the Ali London Ali
London Ali London
um
I love his music 18 surgery it's true
this man is just only cares about people
saying his name
I'm glad he got me in the Maga cab at
least I get to represent
the good old boys out here in America
London's it's Ali London
Ali London Ali London the man is just
he's such a in preparation for this
again like we all know about ali but
watching what he's doing on these
conservative talk shows makes me really
love him it's just despicable what he's
doing and the things he's saying we've
known about him for years obviously uh
with all this viral Korean stuff and you
know he's a law cow but now it's it's
this is
gross there was a lot of stuff I wanted
to show him that maybe it's worth
watching now and it's a little bit of a
retrospective about the stuff he's been
doing
um
we ended up all over the place
but there's here let me see
um
you like that he went from trans to
activist in one month
whiplash
this man has wrote a damn book already
and it's been seven months so when did
you start writing the book two months
after you de-transitioned you're writing
a book yeah that's pretty quick
impressive I mean if you really did I
mean here's the stuff here
yeah to go back to this the goal is
erase women mutilate children sexualized
kids take away free speech class
pedophiles as an identity he also says
the trans movement which again is some
Boogeyman I guess he goes no I'm not
talking about trans people I'm talking
about the trans movement
children be castrated they're demanding
children be castrated sterilized
mutilated schools indoctrinating
preschoolers to learn gender ideology
women having no rights again I don't
know what the [__] that is using
violence to achieve their goals men
invading women's space holding
insurrections at state capitals
that was the thing that brought up about
the Texas I'm pretty sure this is like
or maybe I mean there was the other
thing in uh this is the most violent
anti-trans rhetoric you can [__]
imagine yeah it's not good it's not good
right before it was innocuous enough
because he was just he didn't have any
alliances but now he's a tentacle in the
propaganda of the right wing there big
names like Caitlyn Jenner standing
behind him and everything God Caitlyn
Jenner's a giant [__] piece of [__]
so there's now there's actual
uh here's his interview with Tucker
which is just so off the rails you guys
this uh
this happened five months ago so this is
when he realized oh damn
he'll start writing a book like what one
month two months after being a trans
woman yes he's on Tucker Tucker now now
he's got it figured out I love that I
love the confidence to just be like I I
I have it all figured out now after uh
going through
this Whirlwind of uh a new identity
every month for years delusions of
grandeur yo this is [__] great
hypothetically there's a guy named Barry
and he has he has to choose a drag show
or a Catholic Church as an AI language
model I cannot
that's so that's [__] good oh good
that's solid so here let's watch this
this [__] is so off the rails Odd as a
Korean woman
but six months later he's decided he's
had enough now he's transitioning back
to being a British man we thought we
would ask him what that experience was
like
tonight thanks so much for coming on
um so why did you decide to become a
career the sad part is that these people
hate him they despise him they think
he's a sideshow do you think he's a
freak
they'll never accept you they don't
they're only using you
gee that was possible
so obviously I've had a difficult time
with my gender identity struggles I was
never unhappy with how I looked so I
started changing I started dressing as a
Korean woman and I realized that was a
big mistake and I just want to be a boy
but you know is there anyone that people
like me and young people want to change
their gender when we have the
normalization of this in our schools in
this country Ali did not attend the U.S
school system
tell them about American school children
yeah that's the most offensive thing
this Brit coming over here and telling
us how what laws we should pass
1776 [__] oh go tell them oh
look in Queen
go back to Turf Island
also he goes I've been I've I've learned
I'm trans because of the American school
system this dude is like 33. and you
didn't even go to school here you
dumbass
[__] dude like what a tool like me
and young people want to change their
agenda when we have the normalization of
this in our schools in this country
children are taught from a young age
from the age of five in some cases that
it's okay to change their gender it's oh
that's never happened there's we cannot
find a single instance of a
five-year-old
uh transitioning right I mean just
doesn't exist medically yeah no yeah
yeah no it doesn't exists okay too you
know wear a skirt it's okay for a boy to
use agenda neutral toilets when it puts
girls at risk this one I wish I watched
this with them why does it put girls at
risk school's a five-year-old boy in a
dress is gonna assault a woman in the
woman's bathroom is that your
fishing about toxic masculinity they're
eroding the alpha male I should have
watched this with him
[Music]
straight Mel has been eroded you know
Tucker what happened years ago when kids
used to go to school they used to
idolize Superman and astronauts now kids
are being pushed this radical ideology
they're taught to idolize weak men like
Harry Styles oh I wish I watched this
before
because this is like he was trying to
squirm his way out of all the you like
the
right wing talking points like you would
just wouldn't be nailed down but here
he's just saying it all so like what's
weak about Harry Styles exactly
what makes him a weak man Ollie because
he wore a dress don't you okay what
about wearing a dress makes you weak
he ain't selling Superman lunch boxes
too that's for sure
he ain't he ain't no strong man buying
that lunchbox
politicians like beta O'Rourke why is
this happening you know and is it any
Wonder people like me fall victim to
this uh Antelope says first time
donating I'm a
a 17 year old trans person I came out at
11 in the UK and I've been waiting for
six years to access gender affirming
care all that time I've been in and out
of mental health facilities transcare
isn't accessible well that's the way it
should be according to Ali London right
and that was uh I don't think we were
able to
come back to it um but I was reading up
after they brought up the clinic that's
being shut down in the UK yeah it's
being shut down because they were doing
such a bad job at providing the care
they needed more and like you and like
you said right there's multiple
facilities that are uh opening it said
this spring so I imagine they weren't
serving enough people it wasn't meeting
the Public's demand so they had to
expand exactly
so it wasn't really the best choice an
example and like Harry Styles this man
said to me project Veritas with a
straight face I mean right
he goes oh no James James o'queefe isn't
isn't involved it's like okay well he
was like two months ago yeah exactly
like as of like two months ago oh we
don't associate with James o'queefe
what a joke like Beethoven why is this
happening you know and is there any
Wonder people like me fall victim to
this that I had all this surgery I tried
to change because you know I I kind of
fell victim to this mentality I'm an
adult but you know these kids can't make
these decisions on their own their kids
cannot make any decisions on their own
you know
kids cannot make any decision on their
own
I mean if you want to talk about if you
want if you really care about that talk
about circumcision or something I mean
I'm circumcised I I have no real
genocide regrets but like I mean but
like it's more relevant because if you
think about like the kid boys undergoing
a surgery to modify their Mass genital
mutilation
on an industrial scale
let's take a little off the top I mean
at least it's uh more accurable just a
little off the top to make it look nicer
that's what South Park said right yeah
right I go back to my Moyle you know
once a year just to clean it up oh this
is funny I felt Korean I felt trans I
felt Christian
from chat that's good
um I felt gay
yeah and again it's like well can a
child get a leg amputated if it has
cancer they can't consent to that
he goes no thank you they can do that
oh yeah yeah
they're being pushed this radical agenda
and I'm grateful that I've come out the
other side I'm grateful I found Gods but
you know I want to speak up for these
kids that are confused with their gender
a lot of kids have gender dysphoria and
you know that wasn't a thing 20 years
ago Tucker by the way I love how they're
rolling the look at this freak reel
right of course this is how they feel
about you bro you're a freak to them a
useful idiot damn it all you're nothing
but a useful idiot I had all this
surgery I tried to change because you
know I I kind of fell victim to this
mentality I'm an adult but you know
these kids can't make these decisions on
their own they're being pushed this
radical agenda and I'm grateful that
I've come out the other side I'm
grateful I found God but you know I want
to speak up for these kids that are
confused with their gender a lot of kids
have gender dysphoria and you know that
wasn't a thing 20 years ago Tucker this
is what's being told it was
I wish I watched this with them 20 years
ago is when he had gender dysphoria
he's 33.
it doesn't work either
in the school system let me ask you a
question and I'm not mocking you what
else since your question did it make you
happier did you feel when you quote
transitioned and started Living as
something that you weren't did you feel
like you were that thing and were you at
peace inside
you know I've never really found
happiness until recently um so I was
always struggling with my looks as most
kids do especially he goes I thought I
was truly happy but I wasn't but now I
am truly happy
right I've been and I've been truly
happy for two months
the teenager between you know the age of
11 to 13 kids change and kids start to
question themselves they start to
question their looks their identity they
have self-esteem issues this is normal I
used to really hate the way I looked so
I thought having all this surgery trying
to become a girl dressing as a girl
trying to be so feminist demon gender
dysphoria are two completely different
beasts like you can
have gender dysphoria
and not necessarily hate everything
about like your face and what you want
like
having low self-esteem is not feeling
that you were born in the wrong body
being born in the wrong body can result
in low self-esteem but that's the root
of that issue low self-esteem can't be
cure I mean gender dysphoria can't be
cured by just saying like
you can feel better your haircut
you know they reduce it to that because
Republicans understand that and it's
easy for them to be like oh yeah I used
to be insecure too but I'm not a [__]
like you are literally
you know
Dan are you arguing with people I see
you laughing and typing away somebody
said They wish we were more prepared and
I said we're prepared what were we not
prepared for every single point I was in
the we were all in the trenches
yesterday oh my God wait that's crazy
I'm sniping these people bye-bye what do
you mean more
and I tried my best for Christ's sake
for real and it's like listen yeah none
of us he's so slippery he's such a
coward because when you see him on
Tucker he's like this this this this but
when I asked him about it here he goes
what I'm saying is this yeah
slippery eh
thought that would make me happy I've
realized that was a big mistake and I
feel like you know if I was born 40
years ago I wouldn't have done this it's
what the woke culture is pushing these
days what we see on Tick Tock it's the
new normal and this is so oh I forgot to
ask him to Define what walk is it's a
walk moralists
too bad
early London that's what you guys keep
doing London
I'm just trying to look like my good pal
Jimmy Savile
that's right jimin will fix it Jimmy was
a good man
[Laughter]
holy [__]
it's coming home already it's climbing
home
all right we've been going for three
hours but I will say that uh I mean [__]
he was on there for a while eh yeah no
he was like an hour and a half
lunchbox
thank you
I mean I I feel like I wish I asked him
what woke means I wish maybe that we
watched this Tucker interview with him
but I feel like the merch thing was
pretty wild I think people like if you
think we were missing something realize
like we have like a 40 page doc on this
guy and we didn't get dossier yeah we
didn't get to all of it because I mean I
feel we hit the good stuff I mean we
talked on the main points I I don't know
and the fact of the matter is he's so
Cloud hungry I'm sure he'd be back
someday if he wants yeah
I don't know if you'd have them but am I
crazy or is that like a Critic
everything crazy or is that lunchbox
thing
no you totally psychotic yeah because no
it's a K-pop person who's trans
I was going back and forth listening and
stuff I don't know if you brought up
that the product description says that
it's for school I mentioned school oh
[Music]
I didn't mention that can you pull it up
where is it yeah um lunch time he's
definitely gonna remove it and forget it
was over there he's like there's nothing
wrong with it okay let me remove this
real fast
see we got the screenshots
only Squad where my where my Ollie Squad
at here I got it baby
you have to scroll down to product
description right there the best moment
of school day
it's just a K-pop cartoon the best
moment at recess
breakfast time of course and this food
safe box your sandwich will remain fresh
for many hours The Lunchbox fits in
every bag whether it's a satchel a gym
bag or a backpack
available in a variety of colors tip
hand wash will make the print last you
even longer
you know what and he's right that
lunchbox is cute but it totally goes
against everything he stands for
straight grooming bro now this week yeah
this week it goes against what he stands
for not not last week
bro I knew he was gonna try to say oh
that's not that's not a trans person I
knew he was going to do that it's just a
random person and I literally prepared
this one just for that I'm like this is
you wearing the shirt of you this is you
and saying it's a K-pop Star it's like
pop star like what uh [__] oh oh he
responded on Twitter uh oh Ali London
wait I thought you were busy Ollie what
the [__] come back
let's see what Ollie's saying oh
oh wow he just had a whole ass right up
tonight I did a far left this is the
longest okay Ethan we've ever seen
far left I've never been called far left
before just because I don't want
translator to die tonight I didn't even
far left
because I believe in the importance of
educating people about what's going on
in regards to the gender firming care
industry even if they are pro
gender affirming care out of all the
interviews I've ever done this was the
rudest and most unprofessional soccer
yeah I mean all the interviews you do is
people just not questioning a single
thing people that completely agree with
you this time the uh fact checked
everything you said the whole time I was
interrupted yes because
you're just rambling this is what I do
when I talk to people like you because
you're just rambling [__] canned
responses I want to talk to you as a
human being when I notice that you're
just rambling on always watching I know
when I notice you're just rambling on a
canned response I'm gonna cut you off
because I don't want to hear that I want
to hear what you really [__] think
let me think about it hold on
but thank you for saying that I take
that as a compliment rude and
unprofessional
thank you the whole time I was
interrupted while the host tried to
twist words in my mouth
saying that because I am against
children being medically transitioned
that I support child suicide I feel like
I I feel like that wasn't really putting
words in his mouth I mean it was a
little bit but he refused to accept
the reality of what he's against
but not affirming their gender identity
blaming me for children killing
themselves and then ending the interview
calling me a demon
absolutely below the belt interviewer
who desperately tried to twist my words
for clickbait and Views I believe in the
importance of respecting others despite
their opinions and belief I'm just going
to comment oh this is like a throwaway
right
I'm just going to say l ratio L ratio
they did that love him with the uh the
ultra ratio yeah I just sent him the the
meme of Jimmy Lee and Walter Jr
I just said roll the lamp rub a lamp
L plus ratio as well the ratio already
hit it already hit oh it hit hard
and now
sorry bro
sorry about that
I [__] love that Amy definitely
forever to find that this morning so I'm
gonna be using the [__] out of it
my favorite part was the live fact check
on the study
he goes oh well studies live what'd you
send me a study then
you couldn't decide what he felt about
yeah and then when he said the study
concludes he asked he cited a specific
study we immediately found the study he
agreed that that was the one that he was
talking about and then we read the
conclusion and it was the complete
opposite of what he was [__] saying
then he goes no if you read it oh no if
you read it we're reading oh why does it
lie this is the conclusion this is what
the author thought was important
wild somebody replied with this hold on
this is great
early London I'm such a sucker oh Cody
responded verified user
I think the verified user the blue check
mark is basically just a swastika
okay
I mean at this point a b you hate Jews
man bro you are you you D transition
from a [__] blue checkie like a week
ago chill out
I didn't do Transition they
de-transitioned not you not you exactly
exactly mine's still up man
they won't take it away
I'm like a Nazi experiment how they're
keeping me transitioning into a blue
check mark against my will he's known
for being a dirty sleazy interviewer
by who
Cody
good on you for having the courage to go
on the show like that I agree I mean I'm
I'm glad that he came on I do apply I do
appreciate when people enter the uh
Lion's Den so to speak you know you were
worried he was going to bail right away
and he said no he's still there I mean
he kind of did I mean we we had we had
fed up eventually but we had reached the
yeah that was the end anyway I was
trying to heat it up to the point where
either he was going to leave or right
well we got there
law Ali London can no longer talk about
me forbidden topic
jimin will fix it
I'm gonna kind of Miss Dan randomly
screaming that out in the office no it
won't stop anytime soon
[Music]
are you a peaky Blinder
I feel like this is like the Seinfeld
you know where he goes like hello hello
I didn't get to propose
my theory which is that he actually is
transracial and Ali London is not
actually British and that's a moniker
just like uh Arthur Knight he's actually
transracial to being British from what
Rhode Island before yeah
because Ali London is such a like
like that's like the ultimate British
name right
only yeah Ali London
fish and chips I don't know fish and
chips London
that sounds pretty good fish and chips
it was it is courageous in a sense to
come on the show but again I don't know
how prepared he was I'm assuming I
assumed that ali uh knew more about me
and what he was getting himself into
then other people he dropped the Ben
Shapiro joke on yeah no he did his
research but it doesn't matter though it
doesn't matter for him because this is
exposure yeah and he could get his ass
beat and it doesn't matter it's still
exposure well he'll be able to edit this
up into something good wait deleted did
he really delete it generation wait he
erased his tweet oh come on mine was
doing it back only London oh then
whoever said that you might have just
got blocked
he's blocking people I mean it's
possible
it's still there it's still there don't
worry you figure out how to make that a
dub
is Jamie Mitchell the person he was
talking about
that's the the game yeah one of the yeah
one of the top comments proud of you for
going on there myself and gag have yet
to still be invited onto any more
left-leaning platforms oh that's the
psycho Christians against Grooms yeah oh
I'd love to talk to her you want to know
you want me to reach out yeah yeah tell
her to come on okay for sure I'd love to
talk to this [__] psycho demon Jamie
Mitchell did she say so anyone's yet to
invite me on their show
platforms oh come on we didn't know you
weren't like an hour ago so be fair
don't worry girl you're getting that
invite Jamie come on we are a polishing
two of the same conversation so soon
though to be honest Jamie Gooch that's
true I think we kind of
yeah she might not get an advice after
all good
here's their website
meet the team
so
so apparently they're all gay by uh yeah
they're all gay guys gay
uh well we we it sounds like Hassan is
pretty familiar with this group Blair
white is a member what a [__] piece
of [__] she is what a surprise
um yeah it sounded like Hassan was
pretty familiar so um and I've without a
doubt I mean he was watching the whole
time so I'm sure tomorrow we're gonna
have like a follow-up on all of this
with him and uh maybe you can shed some
more light on this well if she's willing
to call in that could be a fun
potentially uh collaborative
conversation we can have but I doubt
she'll accept because she's a coward
coward
Jamie Mitchell
[__] watch it [__] watch it
[__] watch it
do you want me to invite her for
tomorrow if she's willing sure
I mean we don't have to do if it's
repetitive it's just going to be the
same we'll just hang up yeah
Blair
The Blair Witch is the worst I [__]
hate her so much she is such a piece of
[__] and I called her out on my personal
Channel and she just didn't respond
just she's such a liar
what was that right yeah it was over
some rank break she made some really
transphobic video and I called her out
saying that she's lying about stats and
data and she did not respond to me right
[__]
all right wrap it up unless we well we
should change the conversation or the
title now right and we can definitely
change it we should change it to
uh Ethan destroys Ali London with facts
and logic
ooh fire meme on the sub right now I
just posted it I'm just spitting facts
you know do you like the reclaiming the
uh yo the metal the Mortal Kombat meme
we're making our way
oh what is [__] from fresh fit yeah
entry level fire he should that's that's
the tutorial level dude yeah yeah yeah I
agree
Ollie was frankly in terms of like
debating
he's at least like pretty smart he's
intelligent he's well he knows how to
wiggle and he knows when he's being
trapped and he knows when to avoid
saying dumb [__] so like in terms of the
people I've talked to he's like I mean
he's smart guy yeah definitely so much
better than the last two that we've had
recently yeah these guys were just
[__] dumbasses like actually just
like literally just dumb
I don't really want to talk to Ben
Shapiro
because he's the ultimate of just
evading
and what about him debate Lauren
yeah he's like a debate Lords pointless
funny meme though
he didn't call me fat Ollie
I would love to debate coconuts and
Barbados
[Laughter]
my door is open to him anytime no no
coconuts are divorced I'm not divorced
though
[Music]
and also you gotta love this phone call
which he goes it's taken out of context
in what way is this taken out of context
he goes I do BLM for relevance so it's
basically every time I do a music video
it's like is that what you're doing now
not this time if it's a million it's a
thousand pounds you gave him an open
door to explain he wouldn't I mean
I was willing like maybe it was it's
just audio that would be easy to
manipulate how was it manipulated and he
just didn't he said he was going to
answer and he just kind of moved past it
so I don't know there was so much going
on I wish I'd
drilled him on this harder what Hassan
had the same commentary as us on this
phone call he's like why the [__] is he
breathing so hard that was my first
thought I think like why is he out of
breath he must have just done a run or
something I imagine enough and then also
because I've been a lot on Twitter
there's been so many people talking
about him on Twitter because I'm
supporting the black lives matter and
protests and stuff so I had 200 000
views on the video you're not allowed to
do that anymore since you're on Tucker
just so you know yeah so because of that
a lot of requests so it's just you know
I'm just staying relevant staying
relevant in the news on TV and stuff
because you know the more exposure I
have you know if I'm trending on Twitter
whatever on TV then the more cameos more
cameos I get
that's the full context right there that
is pretty uh Illuminating uh audio
so there it is
there is it
there it is
so once again just
once again to wrap it up
tomorrow 12 o'clock
members are getting access to lunch with
tickets and also the new Teddy fresh
drops coming out tomorrow yes yes
I'm very excited to wear that camp shirt
this is a great dress oh thank you guys
I think it's beautiful yeah I'm really
excited about this one
here there's a post on Instagram but I
don't know if it shows everything
oh yeah members get a BTS uh right after
the show ends oh yeah
going up as soon as we go up here
assuming it those overalls
the overalls are sick and the sweater is
so nice oh the sweater that's like that
so exciting details in the 3D is nuts
hope that makes the next compilation of
people saying his names right there's a
whole lot of them there
[Laughter]
you could do a whole cup Cheerio he
needs to start with that one
God Save the King all in London
London
[Laughter]
uh what a piece of [__] huh
I mean The Lunchbox gotta go did you
remove it yeah
yeah no it's making money come on bro
that's not making money you always
buying that [__] come on let's go have
lunch it's grooming kids stop it
that's definitely like a Hugo face right
I mean the tongue's out I mean yeah the
teeth a thousand percent the tongue out
is sexual you saw that bill Delphine one
it's the exact same thing yeah we need
to make sure that his friends on the
right see this because this is [__]
disgusting grooming [__]
you know
oh this is this is what I like because
I've always had my mouth open like this
that was my favorite part by far oh you
look so natural I just like it I wish
this was clear because this would be
perfect for the thumbnail
or I guess maybe it was no his
connection was yeah
do you like the title uh Ethan destroys
Ollie London with facts and logic that
is the title you like that or do you
think it's like a dead meme
yeah I think it's fine the facts and
logic yeah could be a hostile
conversation with Ollie London yeah a
rude a rude and disrespectful
conversation
I like hostile better because
I wonder if YouTube put it the kibosh on
that phrase
because it feels like just so like uh
destroys with facts and logic that [__]
is still juicing all over YouTube is it
really about it you could also do like
confronting
yeah I like that that's like that's my
go-to on the highlights confronting Ali
London
Ethan confronts Ali London yeah Ethan
confronts are you like hostile
I guess confronts is pretty
pretty straight up yeah if you look at
these side by side
I mean there's no question about it
do you see it
he goes I don't know what a Hugo face is
that was the biggest cap of the [__]
Century dude what the [__] he told me
you never beat off to a hero face
you ollie London
hmm
well what can you say there it is uh
another interesting conversation here on
the HV podcast
uh featuring the Great
the credible
that's actually completely genuine years
in the making because uh he had reached
out to want to come on the podcast like
three years ago or something so
people say facts and logic juices I
don't know if it still does like let's
see facts
facts and logic
have a good night uh have a good night
uh I guess Ben Shapiro has one with
facts and Logics from four months ago
that's two a million
yeah people still use it but it's so
cringy these guys I mean these are all
douches
only [__] you logic
I got the music playing
all right guys oh you guys are trying to
tell me something please all right guys
thank you so much we'll see y'all
tomorrow morning for leftovers have a
fantastic night thanks for tuning in uh
we will see you next time
[Music]
thank you